a great little Italian restaurant in a
wealthy Town Charming staff top food
happy
customers well that's the dream but this
is La Lanterna [__] and it's going down
the pan fast I don't know how longu Chef
rata Alex Scott is so worried about his
business that he hasn't slept for 4
months she has good from [__]
[__] his best mate Gavin runs front of
house but he hasn't got a clue you as a
major D are [__]
useless the food's expensive the
restaurant's empty most nights and Alex
is losing more than a grand a week quit
now if I can't turn this business around
then the lights will go out at Lanterna
for good it's [__] wake up
time
[Music]
just 20 mil north of London leworth is
Britain's first Garden
City slack bang in the middle of town is
Lanterna do it it's run by British born
and bred Alexander Scott hry up from an
early age Alex dreamt of being a chef
screw a bit lemon juice on it and pour a
bit of ol over it then childhood
holidays in Italy turned him into a
selfon best Italian F
qu so much so he's taken to calling
himself Alexandro I think I'm a pretty
decent chef and I know he's a lot worse
and I do take a lot of pride in what I
do I'd like to get to Stage we got a
really good reputation where people
travel from 40 50 M 60 Mi to come here
for a Mill and we have got a really
really good
name like Gordon or Jamie or one of
these other
feathers helping him realize his Italian
dream this polish side El Nova but she's
got more attitude than atude listen to
me come back for
salad trolley yeah tried to do
everything I can to try and build a
business up everything that I can
possibly think of and it's just not what
employing friends an exair Hostess
girlfriend Emily has proved to be a
dangerous mix of business and pleasure
okay new can name I've remortgaged my
house again to inject some money into
the business
uh and took out another personal loan
and sort of beefed up my credit cards
but how long can we
last with debts of more than £180,000
Alex is on the verge of losing
everything he's got looks quite nice
from Thats
side that's why I'm here to find out
what's gone
wrong Chef morning chef nice toet you
very well thank you good and this is it
it is and go
it's it's small Pokey yeah very Pokey Al
Scott executive chef I like those how
many in the team in the kitchen yeah two
us two so that's why the executive
what's with the flags Italian English
Italian English yeah and that's the
style of food is it it is Italian
Italian and you're from um Italy England
oh England I just always worked in
Italian Kitchen so I just sort of learn
to learn the language learn to start a
cooking so lot of Italian ingredients
yeah where the cett from uh from our
butcher from London this morning but Co
Jet's from a butcher and where the
peppers from tesos tesos they're cheaper
are they're cheaper so uh coets of the
butcher peppers from tesos lemons from
Sardinia Cash and Carry so so far I've
seen [__] all
Italian it's Saturday the only busy
night at Lanterna and a chance for me to
take a close look at Alex's authentic
Italian
Kitchen and what's that there that's
speci was used for the canalone packet B
sauce that reminds me of my days as a
hotel commi back in the early '
80s a successful Italian Kitchen has to
understand the secret of great Italian
food simple fresh Italian
ingredients Bing what does Donna do in
service operate the microwave in Alex's
kitchen all the vegetables are
pre-cooked and blasted in the microwave
oh look everywhere like Christmas tree
decorations we need to do our sticker on
the top shelf we've got our
fairy what turns you on about food what
makes you excited about food nothing
really nothing I like me and what did
you do in Poland were you working as a
chef in a tax office the tax office yeah
yeah that's nice so uh why cooking I
don't know I don't I don't know I don't
actually
cook great start a Polish assistant who
won't cook and an English Chef who
seemingly
can't
the but the menu promises modern Italian
cuisine and at 30 quid ahead it's got to
be good to keep the customers coming
back nice if you like
matchmakers have a game of
dominoes the packet graini matches the
decor straight out of a 1980s fake
Italian
teteria
to see what Alex is made of I've asked
him to serve me up some Italian
Classics first up fresh minist
suit this should be a star hit on any
Italian
menu God very very greasy yeah dirty all
slick around the outside I'll pass on
that one what is that oh it's passing on
the
stalk next salisia lagano fresh Italian
sausages baked in white wine and served
on garlic
bread oh
dear dear dear um it looks like two
poodle penises D in parsley I almost
like feel I've gone back to sort of
1982 where every other restaurant in the
High Street was an Italian
ripoff we're now in the 21st century and
they're still serving crap like
this [__]
disgusting even worse the amor cake is
bought in unfortunately not quite
defrosted slightly Frozen in the
center oh dear dear this is about as
authentic as a [__] Chinese
Takeaway right
alesandro you talk passionately about
you know Italian ingredients
authenticity I saw nothing Italian and
nothing done with care I'm concerned
about where you're going how long this
place has got to last and unfortunately
deled [__]
all that was B way way below part do you
think this is funny no no cuz I didn't
find it
funny that was
upsetting cuz that was [__]
dire Alex may think that I'm his worst
nightmare but this really is my idea of
kitchen hell he's in such meltdown he's
even let the most basic standards of
hygiene slip
you think You' have cleaned up I mean
it's not as if he didn't know I was
coming there's no excuse for Filth as
bad as
this when was the last time the place
was really properly cleaned it was
cleaned every Friday afternoon yeah
[__] when was the last time all the
fridges were pulled out pulled out um
that was done about two weeks ago what
about all the bread rolled down behind
the fridge now you can see them from
here look she frows up into the oh
alonna throws bread up into the basket
to dry out to dry out for breadcrumbs
and she misses so it all goes down the
back of the fridge dirty lady what about
this pile of [__] here what about them
with a kitchen in this state Alex risks
further damage to lanter's already
fragile reputation oh [__] hell it's
never been used what about these trays
here when were they done last he could
even be clothed down that if we do that
the the oven doesn't stops working when
we to change it [__] hell are you
ever going to tell me the truth it does
don't worry about the oven breaking yeah
that's replaceable giving a customer
[__] food poisoning is not yeah
yeah look look at that in there that is
gross that is [__] disgusting
everywhere you're turning this kitchen
there's another surprise
look muscles on the floor stuff
everywhere produce just left going moldy
again and then there's a pot noodle on
there who the [__] is eating pot noodles
isy there's 60 Customs out there I am so
[__] glad they can't see where their
food's coming from how it's cooked and
what the [__] is going on behind the
scenes cuz it's a mess and it's a
[__] embarrassment [__]
disgusting oh my God that is taking the
[__] piss [__]
hell
it's my second day at Lanterna where I'm
trying to drag it back from the depths
of
Despair Alex has told me he's tried
everything he can to save the business
the new head chef Alexander promises
exceptional food and an enjoyable
evening for every occasion Lanterna when
only the very best will do [__] me only
the very best we'll do the kitchen's a
[__] dirty filthy
mess Exquisite classic Italian
food God what a [__]
spook radio ad it's going to take a lot
more than that to get this place back on
track when was the last time the fridges
were done last
week that's that's finish from Saturday
night so that's just a special order
Jesus Christ I'm shocked by the levels
of hygiene here I wouldn't even serve
that to a [__] pig you know that Alex
isn't even following the basic rules
there's got to be M no matter what you
doing from a bacon sandwich to a [__]
total of [__] ghost cheese you have
to stay Immaculate oven should be
cleaned after every service the floor
should be spotless and leftover food
should be thrown away or stored in
clearly labeled containers more oh
[__] hell whose fingers have been in
there I I need to throw this stuff away
cuz I'm nervous you know that yeah yeah
yeah [__] you [__] with standards this
luck Alex's authentic Italian Kitchen
look at that in there could be closed
down
who's
that environmental health W
environmental health no no damn Pest
Control Pest Control [__] me do we need
you come in yeah he knows what he's got
to do he just going to check the rack
one Saving Grace they've never had rats
or mice in this
kitchen not right yeah but there is one
pest I'd like to control and that's Alex
he's been scaring around in his own mess
for far too long can you see where we
are now you know um I've had a very um
embarrassing dinner I've come back into
the kitchen the place is in a mess
you've taken Your Eye Off the Ball the
passion's gone and we've really got to
get this thing back up let's get all
that clean without any
[__]
Jason with a clean kitchen I can focus
on the main
problem Alex is
cooking quite frankly it's clearly a
really fortant imitation of 1970s
Italian crap because when you walk into
a kitchen and spot a bottle of lazy
lemon it means lazy bastard nothing
more for me I Lear know where to [__]
start with the food you know because
what I want to do is try and store that
kind of freshness and give it a sense of
Italian style influence but Italian food
wasn't built up on [__] frozen food
run under waterer yeah cuz quite frankly
all I've seen you do so far is reheat
things I know the food's rubbish but I
need to see how he gets it on the
[Music]
plate I've never seen a chef work at
this bre net speed and yet achieve so
little oh [__] hell that little
fucker's got all the energy in the world
but it's just channeled in the wrong
direction cuz he's actually jumping
around doing [__] off he looks [__]
busy but he's actually cooking [__]
badly [__]
porod how's my Red Bull with a diet of
five Red Bulls a day Alex is so wide he
bashes out the food as though his life
depends on
it most of his food comes in Frozen or
from a it and I know
why he's
lazy instead of getting ready for his
customers he'd rather play golf all day
then Rock up an hour before service with
his best mate Gavin
swies there's a woman coming saying she
got table of seven people quart to seven
how many's book now Gavin um I'm going
to need to double count again Gavin is
the restaurant manager the face of
Lanterna does he know what he's doing
out
there we'll have a walk up the road cuz
we think we may have got the wrong place
but it looks like the dining room is
operated with about as much finesse as
the
kitchen you say you want to run it as an
Italian restaurant well maybe 30 years
ago I could understand why this exist
but not
now and quite Frank it's not only
further is it no no weere near it not
with those
yeah
that those yeah I was taught to cook by
uh a very well respected Italian chef
that's total [__] because there was
nothing Italian there nothing
anywhere Alex tells me this
well-respected Chef is still in the area
maybe he can shed some light on the
source of Alex's
[Music]
inspiration are you Mario yes the famous
chef so T yeah you taught Alex
everything he knew is that right yeah
and did you introduce him to bashal and
and Masala
yeah so it was you what I'm the
responsible one he something go wrong
[__] hell Mario where do you want me
to start huh it turns out Alex spent his
formative years with Italian born Mario
known locally as hafer's king of the
tratas and obviously went very well cuz
you know you're a taxi
driver no is up in a stage where I was
for that but key if it doesn't work out
for Alex I suppose I can come bring him
to the rank yeah cuz his food's [__]
rank yeah yeah see but he's a lousy
driver as well he's a lousy driver as
Welling now I'll let you get back to
your rank thank you very much they're
very soft those hands they like baby's
bottoms get back in the
kitchen
Mario morning it seems the extent of
Alex's knowledge of authentic Italian
cuisine stretches no further than Luton
Alex needs to bite the bullet and
relaunch the restaurant with a fresh
identity of his own
but a new image cost money and Alex is
at the end of his tether financially
how'd you pay yourself I haven't paid
myself a wage for 4 months bloody hell I
mean is your business really on the line
of going bust oh absolutely it is very
much so on the line cuz I'll lose
everything the house everything is all
it's all tied up in a business so if it
all goes wrong I walk away with
absolutely
nothing Alex's past seems full of bad
financial
decisions after just 2 weeks of running
Lanterna success went to his head
and instead of getting his cooker fixed
he spent £46,000 on a new
[Music]
car with no spare cash Alex can't afford
to turn the business
around can you [__] slow down a bit
please I'm feeling sick [__] you
H why on Earth did you buy
it truthfully uh I love cars I'm what
I'm trying to say is you think you've
got your priorties right look down at
the number plate do you have a small
dick that you no not all big dick um you
don't need a car for transport to get to
work no no you live above the restaurant
y new commitment yeah big responsibility
absolutely [__] big responsibility
then you go and splash out a [__] car
yeah so we got to recuperate money back
to get back into the business to keep
the business open Abol so we got to sell
it I mean if you had the choice of
keeping the car and closing the
business cuz that's what's going to
happen
shortly lose the car ke the
business at last he's got his priorities
right and with the car up for sale on
the internet I've got him a good deal on
a new
cooker need to get 38 for it to clear
the finance
[__] maybe I can ring around and see we
can get rid of that number plate please
then now let's think of a [__] grade
A Class A
Chef hi Anthony hi I need some help
please everyone knows I have a lot of
respect for TV chef Anthony R
Thompson not really my cup of tea Gordon
not your cup of tea I didn't think it
would be you know that and we know
you're not in need of a penis extension
well quite exactly that um you're not
interested John Chris he's got a massive
ego isn't he John Chris nelli I'll give
him a call hey Jason see please I'm I'm
trying to no listen I'm trying to sell
it listen to
me I'm going to kick your [__] you
going to kick my hey hold on a minute
I'm going to ask you what's wrong with
the private play
then how am I going look like my with a
[__] with the car and the number
plate up for sale we can move forward
it's time to get Alex to do something he
clearly hasn't done for a very long time
I want him to start
cooking this is a way of taking all your
frustration out yeah in your gra Alex
needs all the help he can get and I want
to see if any of his kitchen staff have
hidden talents I want each of you to
make a pizza Whoever has the best
tasting Pizza we'll put it on the menu
tonight as a special I've discovered
that Joe the kitchen Porter has trained
as a cook explain yours to me Peppa
uh-huh mushroom cheese nice tomato sauce
mushrooms
onion and Chef Alex Four Seasons with
Ary chokes green peppers black olives
and Palam with a little bit of bzel
flash bastard okay Joe here we go excuse
me do you want to come into our
restaurant to try some pizza we just
made thank you here we go right Joe just
explain to the lady what we done have
you got two seconds we've just made
these amazing pizzas and one this lady's
coming to taste him would you come in
and just taste him with us you look like
a man a little bit undernourished bring
on the pizza Alexandra and I bet you're
a vegetarian I am oh there we have a
vegetarian pizza how long have you a
vegetarian about 8
years what I didn't realize was that
Alon put Palmer Ham on the base of her
mozzarella and tomato
pizza Carla um which one did you
actually prefer the last one that I
tried uh the last one I would go for
that one the mozzarella one
unfortunately that's got lots of
mozzarella and tomato but underneath
that it's Palmer ham oh no that was me
no no I didn't know that this is the
lady who made them come forward Al come
here there you go see well done never
made pizza in your life you converted a
vegetarian yeah okay would you like some
more no thank you oh come on there's
nothing wrong with you now you haven't
come out in a big
rash take care good luck with the
veite
fresh food on the menu marks a new start
for
Lanterna but it's going to be a huge
step for Alex goodbye
Plastics
Jesus look at that in there people are
eating that it's so strong this Dem it's
not going down sink no it's all
here I'm banning all traces of plastic
sauces from the premises now Alex will
have to cook from fresh when you open
this up in an attempt to slow Alex down
in the kitchen
I'm cutting his menu by half why have
you got three chicken dishes on Just for
variation trying to give people more
Choice yeah well I've seen all three of
them and I think they're all [__] you
know that because they're all clogged
with the same [__] sauce two of them
can go and I'm not doing that or saying
that to put you in the [__] but you are
in a position to regenerate rejuvenate
those customers and put a little bit of
freshness a lot of excitement into your
customers you know that yeah with a
limited menu and some new dishes tonight
is Alex's big chance to prove to me that
he's capable of cooking from
[Music]
fresh it's something I'd expect one of
my most Junior chefs to pull off without
a
hitch hey check on one porn cocktail two
parmesana one soup first table in so
normally Alex Goes Like
This Jesus Christ then everyone gets
really dizzy first time oh [__]
Dam slow down yeah I want to really make
sure that you stay nice and calm yeah Y
and show some composure now yeah but the
kitchen's only half the
story for the evening to run smoothly
the dining room's got to be well managed
by the mat
D specials sorry excuse me but the mat D
is Alex's best mate it's Gavin's first
job as a restaurant manager and I don't
think he's got a clue we have a couple
of portions left very nice I did have
that for dinner before I started highly
recommended okay it doesn't help that
Gavin's supported front of house by
Emily Alex's
girlfriend the chicken was cold 70° when
I appr it what do you want to do
anything nothing wasn't cold her only
experience of serving food comes from
seven years as an air hostess that's why
I probe
everything you are the major aren't you
you're running the place but you've got
to get some Authority around you know
that you got to get some presents look
at those per rolls over
there that's how big your bollock should
be that big now find them and [__]
use them
just a
drizzle Alex yeah ni and come oh yeah I
actually Alex isn't doing too badly but
it's not long before Gavin's way out his
death he should be taking orders now
now huh what is he doing out
there Gavin's managed to get 60 people
booked in for
tonight but he's allowed 40 of them to
arrive at the same
time I think we're going to be in the
[__] in 10 minutes time you know in a
[__] dog
[__] any manager worth his weight should
know he's got to stagger the bookings to
keep a steady flow of orders coming into
the
kitchen you okay now yeah yeah good you
don't look at [__] scrape off the little
bit Yeah okay put it up there and call
it
out it what is it tell me what it
is hell here we go
again
returns still one under pressure all
Alex's bad habits come flooding
back he's all out of [__] order first
time in his entire career he's actually
had to cook properly and it's pretty
obvious he can't do
it completely in the [__] and lost it
big
time next nothing together CU she has
problems and he's just clammed up and
and I got a good mind to get that number
plate off that [__] car and stick it
up his ass sideways
start Alex and Gavin are like two little
boys playing at Running a
Restaurant I've never worked like this I
hate saying it but so close to Cowboys
you know
that quit now yeah put the rest up for
sale I'm more than halfway through my
week at Lanterna but last night's
attempt at putting freshly cooked food
on the menu proved a total
disaster Alex has a long way to go if
he's going to become a half decent
Italian chef and his mate Gavin gives an
equally pathetic
performance it's just so frustrating
when you show them time and time again
the perfect opportunity for a great
local Italian eery in the middle of a
very wealthy
town and you could make such a great
business out of it but I don't know if
they've got it you jumped up little
[__] prick who the [__] do you think
you are because you as a major D are
[__]
useless I've done it to upset you so you
come back to me I'm going to have to
teach G how to get tough if he's going
to have any Authority deep breath tell
me exactly what you think right now
let's going through your head and get
off your chest with his staff and his
customers get it out I'm ready for this
look there's no one here for [__] s
we're in the middle of a field you've
got to have authority and customers have
got to walk in there looking for you
yeah and you got to get a reputation yet
at the moment I just see this sort of
little Lost Boy moping around and
there's things that going on in that
dining room that you should be aware of
yet you're totally clueless so I'm
really nervous that you're not
supporting Alex properly so what I want
you to do is start getting angry right
why did you send that stop that sounds
like a [__] [__] in a quiet the
golden rule in any dining room you have
to be in control of your staff what the
[__] did you do you [__] idiot like
that and not let your staff control you
why was that food Tak stop that's not
good enough he sound like a right
[__] limp dick what the [__] are you
doing taking the food to Table Six not
table seven you [__] idiot you
[__] idiot can you not read the order
in the kitchen excellent Gavin needs to
gain the respect of his team so they
know who's the boss then he can start
running the restroom with a bit of FL
now you really found your bollocks okay
give it all this time okay what are you
doing you stupid idiot where's your
[__] brain tonight is it up your
ass during last night's service Alex
looked a right mess one this feel for
Gord to have a wind for see if he
notices
I think you're a dirty [__] show me
your
fingernails [__] h i want you looking
Immaculate smiling up and just lifting
that whole sort of image any chance to
give him a quick clean up yes that's
fine yeah don't go too close in case it
bite with a fresh clean Alex I want a
fresh clean look for the
menu Alex has confess that he doesn't
eat fresh fruit vegetables or fish if
we're ever going to make this restaurant
work I've got to get to develop a better
sense of taste for decent food get the
[__] Vine folds on I'm putting
swordfish on the new menu and I want
Alex to choose the pasta that will be
served with it and you look younger with
that gun today you know that huh a lot
younger right first one quite an
interesting one this one we're starting
with a strong blue cheese there you go
open white thank you there you go nice
fine noodles go I had a hint of light
like light pesto type light pesty that's
not
nutty I think you're [__] nutty you
know that this is an intriguing one the
second one you can actually smell what's
on there you know that open white next
up fresh herbs and olive oil definitely
freshly chopped herbs in there not uh
fresh chopped herbs that's interesting
not dried not dried yeah that's not bad
finally something I found lurking in
Alex's
ladder okay this one say
spicy so um that was very nice actually
yeah very toas is it
uhhuh more Saucy than the other two but
still very nice out of all three pastas
which one would you serve with a
swordfish i' say the last one the last
one yeah I'll say the last one oh for
[__]
sake Alex's taste buts have been sulled
by plastic sauces for too
long the last one was a [__] pot
noodle is
it a curry pot
noodle pot noodle
I've got to awaken his senses and give
him a standard to aim
towards neighborhood since I first met
him Alex has blamed everything but
himself for his lack of
success FR produce so I'm taking him to
a neighborhood restaurant that sustained
a great reputation for 14 years based on
simple Italian cooking um this just's
been here since um the O Franchesco
morning gentlemen morning uh how are you
very well very good to see you you um
Alex has got a a small um how would you
call it modern Italian yeah plastic
Italian restaurant in leworth um for me
the most important thing is just to look
at the size of this kitchen yeah this is
smaller than yours yeah you don't need a
big kitchen to prepare good food no you
got one stove there one stove what's the
secret behind Italian cuisine what is it
Simplicity Simplicity Simplicity is
freshness of ingredient that's so no pot
noodles no no no interesting no no
frozen food either no frozen food piglet
in the oven at the moment oh lovely
piglet lovely very simple rosemary
garlic feno seeds nice and how you
serving that uh just with rasted
potatoes do a very light gravy and do
you use any bmall sauce no
no I've been in here 5 minutes I am
absolutely
starving thank you I want Alex to taste
the difference between his Frozen bought
in ravioli and something in an Italian
Kitchen can be proud to serve I want you
to tell
this
yeah really nice fresh flavor pumpkin un
like clean clean anything stuck to the
roof of your mouth no no no stud must
have fruit there really nice Sage butter
are you capable of doing something like
this definitely absolutely but do you
really want to do it I really want to do
it am I wasting my [__] time not all
not all you'll see a big difference it's
been a big wake up called last couple
days and it's going to get me into Focus
get the St into focus and get things to
how they should be
and get things working again but I'm
quite nervous because I think you'll let
it fall through your fingers it will
work not option but if it doesn't work
and you don't wake up what will you do I
will wake
out I I will stick in it I hope you do
it I will but I don't think you will I
will and I'm telling you that in order
for you to prove me wrong yeah and I
will prove you
wrong and just before we go I mean
you're a great Chef aren't you nice car
nice car um what about the number plate
can I sell you the number plate A1 Chef
um how much is it going for the car no
the [__] number plate 18800 1800 so
would you have a private number plate no
no even though you're an A1 Chef yeah
you still wouldn't have a plate no so
what the [__] are you doing with it on
your
car Alex has had his car number plate up
for sale for the last week and we're
praying for some good
news Reserve [__] unfortunately your
item did not sell I was rather hoping we
can get rid of it today you know and
have a conclusive sale
yeah it's not the result Alex was hoping
for but with ler in desperate need of a
revamp I want to show him it's possible
to change the look of the restaurant
without spending lots of
money the interior was designed by
Alex's girlfriend Emily and then we've
got rustic brick work down the end
but her ideas seem to be based on dodgy
hotels she stayed in as a chart of fly
air
hostess for the price of a couple of
tins of paint we can rid Lanterna of his
1980s traera look Charles I don't think
you should touch him we'll go with
Emily's
she's whose restaurant is it is it yours
and Alex Alex is Alex's Restaurant it's
Emily's Last Choice it's Gastly so I
think she she should have less of an
involvement next time round you don't
trust me last color it's not because I
don't trust you I think it needs to be a
substantial Improvement Emily on pale
walls Alex is your
restaurant get your goodies out and make
a decision i' like to go
darker it's lanna's first birthday
tomorrow night and a perfect opportunity
to relaunch the restaurant right just
can be soon but in order to make it work
Alex has to be completely committed to
his
kitchen it's really exciting making nice
homemade soups yeah and when you think
of Italian restaurants you always think
of stuff being homemade I'm replacing
the disgusting Minon soup with the rich
Tuscan bean soup instead have a quick
look at the menu y yeah I'll done and
read the
menu I've slimmed down the menu from a
three-page epic to a simple handful of
classic Italian dishes all freshly
cooked by
Alex now look of it yeah what do you
think of the prices and I've cut his
prices to give value for money not a
concept Alex has ever been familiar with
and that sets you up with 15 to 20
portions of soup at 4 a portion flavor
£80 return that you've got to put 12 to
15 minutes love into it y it's [__] all
you know
that I want Alex to have every chance of
making it a
success get rid
of just see how elegant that is nice and
white Kevin what you reckon much in
white the paper tablecloths cost next to
nothing and the paintings come courtesy
of a local art college Alex what do you
think [__] BS isn't it it just looks
great absolutely
great with a fully booked restaurant for
the relaunch comes Alex's chance to
forge a new reputation okay guys big
night new menu y lots of exciting fresh
ingredients new dining room so walk
around with a little bit of Grace and
put a bit of passion into it yeah as if
you really want it yeah this this is
something is LAN last bite of the Cherry
okay Tusk bean soup very simple if Alex
and his troops can remember what I've
Tau then there's just a chance tonight
might be a success on the top okay can
we just highlight the bottom of the menu
here very very quickly today's
celebration first anniversary Lana
restaurant from now on Alexander Scott
will not be using microwaves or
synthetic sources and I so [__] mean
that you know that yeah okay ready yep
let's go good luck just really hoping I
don't I couple make any mistakes just
really want to get it right just uh just
want go and say yeah you did good we're
okay okay is good Alex has got all the
right ingredients here to make a bloody
good business but can he pull it off
[__] knows one order one sausages one
soup main course is one polo what two
swordfish yes shf yes CH that's
better gently no no no just gently
gently we filled the dining room with
some of Lew's local dignitaries but as
the guests start piling in one suit one
the cracks in Alex's cooking begin to
show so two sausages
[Music]
yeah
go get crazy ready yeah but then start
start
doing long
time are you almost ready with the B I
got eight potatoes yeah how long I don't
know how long keep it together yes Laura
how's everybody out there yeah what they
saying about the
food I mean we've been in here now hour
and a half father
slow we're not a lot of very happy
Banners at the moment I don't think an
hour and 15 minutes we've had an olive
can we reorder and have breakfast
instead call [__]
[__] Alex seems to be falling at the
first hurle we need two leaks
fre Alex yeah talk to don't know do I'm
bit lost at I know I know I know you
lost but what we've just gone really
really really quiet you know that ad
what can you find time CU I keep
repeating everything there's only one
man who can get us out of this mess and
help Salvage Lantern's reputation get me
Gavin please take P right Gavin hello
kitchen is in the [__] yeah that's
pretty obvious yeah it's a big night
tonight the night we should be in the
ship hello yeah how many Linguini have
you sold uh not many I don't think many
at all we hav sold one yet ni yeah so in
order to help the kitchen start pushing
the [__] Linguini a little bit Yeah
so we can take a bit of weight off
Alex's shoulders yeah and push the soup
as well something that we can really
start flying the STS out please yeah
okay sure let's go I want Gavin to show
some bottle if he can motivate his team
and start selling the ready prepared
specials that will take the pressure off
Alex and get the kitchen back on
track well done let me just tell he's he
sold so on the squashing here now he
just sold another four portions hey done
yeah welcome back what did we discuss in
the field the other day about having
what profal balls Kio yeah pereral balls
that's exactly that there you found them
excellent well done yeah uh you just
made the restaurant yeah another 15
quid by Gavin pushing the specials is
giving Alex some space to calm down and
start cooking like a proper
Chef one blue o la la blue get this one
right especially on night like tonight
yeah after the last 2 and 1 half hours
of [__] Mayhem yeah with the right
sort of encouragement he might just pull
it off I bet you ever cook it no I don't
I bet you [__] do I'm apologizing now
because Alex will overcook the Blue
Steak again right okay
sorry
gra it's hardly dinner at the chiani but
it's not bad no this one
blue and the customers are liking it
too
nice very
nice I never thought I'd say it look at
that swordfish but thanks to gav's
Newfound confidence the leworth boys
have come
good Rome wasn't built in a day but at
least I've B Alex Kicking and Screaming
into the 21st
century very good excellent so far very
good timing's a little bit slow but
otherwise very good yeah it's been
excellent tonight it was something B
different something a bit different
about about it the source you know it
was just it was excellent Happy First
Birthday yeah may your second be even
better um Emily happy with the dining
room yes that is a pathetic answer that
means no I [__] hate it I've asked
Alex to make sure that you don't get a
paintbrush in your hand again St yes R
man I'll take you down that field again
you know that all right say it to me
once more what the whole lot the whole
[__] life the whole [__] the whole
[__] life I'm positive in front of
your colleagues where's your [__]
brain tonight is up your [__] ass why
the [__] did you take table six's order
to table seven you stupid
wanker that's
fantastic I really want them to succeed
but it'll take a lot of commitment and
hard work to make this place a real
success so cheers guys Cheers Cheers
chin chin
cheers oh you smooth bastard
huh oh my God 6 weeks later and I can't
wait to see how things are going at
Lanna Farah how are you well thank you
she screamed that I what's going on
about you last night seriously you had a
dream about me last night I thought you
a neighbor killed you you're not wrong
there you know that yeah when I first
visited I found chef papata and Scott
Living in a Dream World I don't know how
long he believed he was a talented
Italian chef but his kitchen was filthy
I wouldn't even serve that to a [__]
pig you know
that the food was Dire and overpriced
[__]
disgusting and to make matters worse his
restaurant manager Gavin was a wimp you
as a MJ are [__]
useless no wonder Alex was drowning in
De and about to lose his home and his
business
I've never worked like this you know so
close to Cowboys you know that after a
week of hard slot Lanna was reinvented
and given the potential to become a
great Neighborhood Restaurant look at
that swordfish beautiful now I'm back to
sa if my time at Lanterna had any
lasting effect excuse me you don't walk
in hey after the way you shouted at me
I'm sorry I thought at least you [__]
make a bit of presents how are you you
right yeah no louder how are you you
okay crap come on where theck the [__]
have you been the last [__] two
months been [__] hanging around
waiting for you you lazy [__] bastard
how are you not well thank you good to
see you well that's better excellent
where's elon's Christmas tree of
vegetables little stack they've all gone
now do them all to order everything's
done to order thank God those revolting
overcooked vegetables are off the menu
overall the whole star enthusiasm is
lifted uh and you look cleaner show me
nails not bad
stuck in the car wash for 3 weeks huh I
feel re you know refreshed reinvented
I'm happy about what I'm doing you clean
CER gets done every morning I can't
believe what I'm seeing it get stri down
door show me surprise me Alex yeah
that's not bad so what's that in there
that's my um mix with my Al to so it's
just [__]
me [__] me serious I'm speechless Alex
is actually cooking done here we have
ravioli filled with mushrooms and warut
Jesus Christ [__] hell you're right
yeah he surprised me I know he surprised
me um you know you know a little bit
sort of surpris in shock thank you I
didn't think you're capable of doing it
the amount of time I'm spending in the
kitchen now is like St about 4 hours
more to what I was doing and the more
work and effort and the more care you
put into food the more it hurts when it
goes wrong oh absolutely so you know
it's an interesting relationship and it
looks like you've now started to sort of
really wake up and understand that bond
with food each time I make like the
raviol I'm improving every time uh
obviously tasting the food is is better
than using the fresh ingredients M well
we've talk the talk y now I want to eat
the [__] food okay good yeah
yep I hope his extra commitment in the
kitchen is reflected in the standard of
his
food you can close your eyes and
actually count flavors the seps the
walnuts the pasta very
good I'm pleased to see he's stuck to a
small very simple Italian menu and
everything's freshly
cooked this is the kind of
food it should be seven
real party rustic wholesome Italian food
rich with tomatoes nice texture in the
meatball
and a perfectly cooked Linguini
lovely [__] me is leworth ready for Alex
Scott Alex has come a long way since his
plastic sources just 6 weeks ago last
time you're struggling to sort of live
survive depending on credit cards yeah
in the ship yep we we cleared I mean
Christmas we basically cleared off all
our debts all our business and personal
debts y started a freshh started a new
year with a clear bank balance uhhuh uh
paid off all the back dating rent and
you know we're standing around 2T now
and we're having a good janary compared
to everyone else in the area even though
he still got the car Alex has managed to
clear £20,000 worth of
debt bit calmer in here now isn't
it and can finally afford to pay himself
a
wage not Crow
yet but there's still one thing standing
in the way of Alex's
success and that's Alex I sincerely hope
he doesn't try to run before he can walk
I just want Gordon to come back in years
time and say yes Alex you are an A1 Che
Mas
delicious unfortunately just um battered
to [__] ve we'll pass that on please
between them they've learned how to
crack the egg battered to [__] literally
he was hoping for like a nice big piece
of ve no texture but apart from that
very nice but they haven't yet made The
Omelette You' been uh cooking now for 6
weeks yeah cuz that's all I'm going to
say that you're cooking properly for 6
weeks and it takes years you know that
oh yeah absolutely please don't forget
that oh no it's a big wake up called
going to Rea just really sort of work
out to what can be done on small
premises yeah using fresh ingredients
what you're saying is that you're no
longer a [__] cowboy absolutely 100%
so when you think that things are going
perfectly right and you don't really
need to improve think back the days of
powdered stock yeah but you always learn
that that and put the shits up yourself
cuz there's going to be no one here in 5
minutes to do that for you do it
yourself now yeah absolutely I think for
your help really appreciate it thank you
Just One Last Thing Before I
Go Gary yeah mate it's Gordon how are
you mate listen I need a favor I'm a
little bit in the [__] to be honest now
Gary Rose is truly an A1 Chef I can give
it to you for £
2,998 you got to be joking for that kind
of money I'll s you mine one hold on a
minute you've got a number plate with
you haven't got the same have you I've
got 22 gr 22 gr there you go
[__] give it to me for less and I'll
think about it 5id I'll take you okay
mate 500 quid
listen quid I'll go back to him 500 quid
and hopefully we sold the [__]
thing DPL Cafe Bar is Indie [__] people
don't eat out that surely are you taking
the piss we give it a bit of a Polish
we're going to do horrible food let's do
horrible food all the time you put like
this in France it'll hang you upside
down from the AL for your vs you know
that I've got just 7 days to transform
the food and banish the [__] you
know the oven's not even hot enough to
roast a potato we can't even cook a
[__] Burger in there but the staff
are at War you don't look an idiot okay
because the someone you're [__] [__]
and if I'm going to get this place back
on track go fre Dage quick something's
got to give those aren't interested in
pulling on the [__] rope [__] off I
you had enough of this hang on hang on
let me finish are you ready for this yes
big day don't [__] it
up
Essex an ancient Saxon County more
recently colonized by Essex girls boy
Racers and footballers wives and now I'm
Mexican Colin Dave called Israel final
what he's not
here 5 years ago he brought trendy
Fusion Cuisine to the heart of chelsford
he opened depl Cafe Bar and it seemed
that he'd found a winning
formula great place great music great
great service great food the right price
and he worked perfectly over the space
of 2 years Israel built a mini Empire of
five
businesses but success didn't last
long 3 years later all but depl are gone
even this place is hanging on by a
thread if I don't do something drastic
then you know this business will go down
the
pan having invested
£150,000 and with a quar of a million
pound loan from a national br
Israel and his partner Tara are at the
Wit's End so you've had the success
there place was busy now almost pissed
through your hands classic example in
business trying to run before you could
walk without consolidating how quiet is
it it's as bad as it's ever been the
restaurant's losing money the the bar is
supporting the restaurant your sales
have dropped by more than 50% in
comparison to 2 years ago how desperate
are you to get it back very very
desperate I'm at the crossroads do I
still give you another go or do I return
the keys to the landlord next month and
say I better go and do something else we
don't know the kind of guy that will
give in easy no I don't Israel is up to
his neck in debt and doesn't even have
the security of owning the building if
this goes tits up he and Tara will lose
everything I I said to you 10 second in
a last ditch attempt to win back
customers Israel has employed onetime
wannabe fighter pilot now high flying
executive Chef Philip Blaze can I have
two avocado and shrimp with 25 years
experience Miss Blaze came hot from the
multi-million pound Stables of belgo and
Planet Hollywood I thought well why not
give a try you know to the countryside
of England at Planet Hollywood I had 150
people working for me you know so here
it's a lot different you know I've got
two three chef you know we get some
great feedback but the only problem is
that the guests don't come
in even on a dead CT like Valentine's
night out of 84 available seats only 24
have been booked but at least that means
the m and I can get a table Happy
Valentine's
Day from the Valentine's special menu
I've ordered a scol and shrimp cocktail
for Mains and a tiasu crem for dessert
sorry I decided to bring it myself
because I had trouble getting a waiter
thank you okay you're
welcome mik wave rice stra away
God just a just a mess really I we got
nice scups they just need cooking sort
of 10 seconds each side but they're chew
with overcooked dried prawns the [__]
there
Dave Dave Phil's Nemesis and mat D is
25-year-old Essex boy Dave bone I think
you need to have quality rather than
quantity on a night like tonight treat
people with the respect they want and a
special manner how does your meal seem
we'll go straight to the CR I think
straight away didn't you ask the ti Mar
say isn't it a
t so do you work
here straight to dessert please rubbery
overcooked I'm sorry I said rubbery and
overcooked
and I'm not the only one complaining I
ordered salmon and um which sounded
lovely and but it just wasn't quite cook
at least my pudding should be a safe bet
it's a French classic so Philip should
be able to make it with his eyes
closed and it looks like he
has CR Bru it's liquid it's a first for
me actually I've never had a runny crule
should ask for a straw it's [__]
embarrassing with oh come on it's not
all right exuse me then
no like listen to me I don't want to I
don't want to I'm the person who looks
an idiot no no no you don't look an
idiot because someone you're [__]
[__] Dave go back to your
restaurant angl French relations seem to
have hit a new
low yeah and I'm saying to you when it's
ready I will
ring here we are in Valentine's night
all I can hear is the [__] Chef she
in the kitchen let's
go we made hard work of nothing and what
I didn't experience was any passion well
I did think that uh the scale of dish
was was actually very very good the ones
I ate were like
rubber and I'm really sorry but I've
never known a Frenchman to make such a
[__] CR Bru in all my
life we got a lot of work to
do [__] me awful food bad service cool
[__] hell definitely not the place
for me [__]
me Israel and Tara have sunk everything
they own into de place and they're
hugely indebted to the
brewery the odds are really stacked
against them but I like them and I also
like a
challenge I want you out of the kitchen
goodbye you can go to the
toilet lunchtime in the kitchen is the
busiest time time of the day and Phillip
is back to his normal menu I'm really
hoping it's a damn side better than last
night's crap otherwise we really are in
the [__] [__] cheeseburger th Nole
the th Nole coming now with over 40
dishes to choose from Philly's menu is
global both in size and choice what is
that this is Sala
[Music]
sauce everything from all day English
breakfast hoisten noodles to Mexican
platters this is definitely more
confusion than Fusion some of it even
served in a bread bin people don't eat
out that shy are you taking the
piss well we we give it a bit of a
Polish 70% of Philip's food is brought
in ready prepared what's happened to
that the Frenchman even gets his
baguettes delivered Frozen [__] hell
and buying readymade food is an
expensive false economy what's the most
popular dish today uh the ham hamburgers
and the crabs are they homemade yeah yes
they
are oh finally thank you very much
[__] rang it Philip's two Sue chefs
mun and alamer are young and
inexperienced they clearly know nothing
Beyond Phil's warped culinary world and
what's that in there sauce uncle uncle
Bening know when do you want to be a
head
chef three years [__] me you better move
your your ask all right where have they
all G now I've got table here ready M
where do you want to be a head
chef well maybe in about 10 years time
10 years time yeah probably have my own
place I think that's what I would like
they may be hungry for success but if
they think this is cooking they're in
for a surprise very lumpy that isn't it
no it looks like [__]
porridge the bells the bells can you
tell me if this is stter and this main
course or is it all
together yeah please because I can't
guess you didn't take a isas the one
which was here was the greek
salad lunchtime service should be a
quick turnaround but with all the [__]
UPS the customers are lucky to get their
food within 45
minutes and it's not helped by the full
scale War ranging between restant
manager Dave and
Phillip what is it between you and Dave
cuz you hate each other right uh pretty
much and when the food does eventually
make it out to the customers it comes
boomeranging back just as fast what's
up which
one it's my mistake obviously uh I
should have spotted it before it went
out and it's not just the undercooked
fish that slipped through Philip's net
what happened she just said it running
what's going on here the plates are
Fuller coming back than they are going
out not she he said it's not cooked
property it's not what no it's not
cooked property it tastes [__] study and
[__] disgusting how many's cooked
there Burgers can be barbecued grilled
or fried but the secret to success is to
cook them to order look how thin they
are we don't cook burgers now they're
not even on order uh we precooking them
either for tonight or even for tomorrow
because the thing is is for tomorrow the
thing is the oven is it's very very slow
and we can't put it any higher than that
have you lost the plot no have you gone
a little bit [__] bour no and so how
you going to cook that again
tomorrow uh it will be reheated in the
microwav holy
mackerel and the torturous treatment of
innocent food doesn't stop there and you
deep fry the bacon
now we do yeah would you cook like this
in France
well uh you'd be [__] shot FR hey
they' hang you upside down from the Al
Tree on by your vs you know that we're
in the
[__] well if we want to turn the
business around yes uh I I have to
agree we are in the [__]
[Music]
[__] Cafe B place is in deep
trouble in the last year food sales have
dropped £7,000 a week and depressingly
since I arrived I found few positives to
build on it's time for Israel to pull
his head out of the sand and smell the
coffee looking at the situation I can
actually confirm I'm [__] myself um
I'm worried about the situation in the
kitchen the idea of cooking there's not
a lot of that going on in there no the
standard pretty crap and what I have
identified lately is lack of Pride yeah
and a huge lack of respect too many
individuals like you've got now will
completely [__] the business but have
you lost respect for your
business no I lost sense of Pride for
the business it starts from the top you
have to stay [__] strong on top of it
because Without You determination we F
and we need to turn their attitudes
around get their heads out their
[__] and [__] get this place back
on track
the animosity between Dave and Phillip
is dragging the business down they're
like a winging old couple so on day
three it's time to start building
bridges with some tried and tested
marriage guidance tactics hold out your
hand so whil you've got that egg in your
hand tell Dave what you really think
about
him well Dave you're just just an
arrogant little
bastard uh you know you think you know
everything you're the most beautiful
you're the most perfect guy there is and
uh that's the bottom
line and
now I think you're talking out of your
ass aren't you cuz when I do try and
talk to you if I do shout it's because
you argue and don't let me finish so
from now on stop being a stubborn
[__] French bastard because we're not
going to work at all and this place is
going to go
down there's nothing that I would like
more than actually being able to work
with the manager of the restaurant and
this whole exercise is not
personal it's about business and doing
your [__]
jobs and I just beg you both to continue
talking to another cuz that hasn't taken
place understand each other's jobs now
shake
hands for the
better it's not just fil's relationship
with Dave that's worrying
me he seems to have lost any real
command of his kitchen sh can I have
vegetable
no an efficient Brigade thrives on
constant motiv ation from their head
chef but M and alamer are left to fester
in bottles sauces and frozen deep fried
food mus like that before where breaded
mushrooms breaded mushrooms yeah they're
picking up one bad habit after another
and Phillip doesn't even seem to care
being in Essex you know people tend to
like the omelet well Co so this is an
Essex omelet not a French omelette oh
it's not a French omelette no okay holy
mackerel show me
yeah that's uh that's [__]
C it's time to find out what happened to
Philip Blaze executive chef
extraordinaire I see a man in front of
me at 40 years of age French that's had
bloody good jobs before at an executive
[__] level whether it's Belo or
Planet Hollywood but I don't see
anything that resembles a chef if you
are buying so much food in
and it's making you look [__] yeah why
aren't you fighting against that chefs
fight for reputations and show the
hunger the customers of making them
happy it's true up to a point yes I may
have given up because I see that there's
no hope but I am still as hungry as I
was to actually do and create things
okay well I want to help you and I want
to work closely with you to get things
back online just to install that little
bit of [__] normality Pride you just
said
it get it
back when a business stops making money
it's tempting to stop investing in it
and it's blatantly obvious that's
exactly what Israel's done the dining
room is Tatty and the kitchen is lacking
some of the Basic Essentials you've got
to give this man the tools in order to
operate this [__] restaurant properly
I'm I'm frustrated that we got a freezer
full of crap and we got an oven that
doesn't work so we got to get our
priorities right your business you're
employed as the head chef you both have
to start speaking the same language
that's absolutely critical I hope this
is the beginning of things to change and
if you leave has felt in the past that
he's been put under pressure to cut
Corners uh not to cut corners without
talking to me say no I don't with the
lines of communication open and the
promise of vital equipment on the
horizon Philip and I can start thinking
about the food do you not think the menu
is too big yes it is maybe finally we're
starting to get somewhere to pull in
lunchtime diners is out with Fusion
confusion and in with a Snappy menu of
tasty fresh food that can be pushed out
quick you see what I'm trying to do I'm
just trying to lift it I don't want to
get complicated these guys of course
aren't in a position to get anything
complicated done that's pretty
how much it C and Phil come up with a
classic French Sandwich to get our
creative juices flowing so you're quite
passionate about the cop Miss I do like
it yes when you're so passionate about
something as nice and delicious as this
how can you make that baguette with the
chicken and the plastic cheese I know
this is water prod duct back for you
you're a Frenchman this surely must be
the kind of food you like cooking it is
cuz I've seen you more relaxed in the
last 10 minutes than I have in 3 days
yeah yeah be nice for you to give a
little bite to the guys and tell them
about it show them a little bit of sort
of you know your passion at last some
real food and it smells delicious all
the way from
Dijon H you're happy with that one
aren't you m that's
beautiful very nice yeah awesome what do
you think I I
like baguette chicken baguette of C mure
I think a cop mure is much better cuz it
looks better tastes better we're going
to take a picture why are we taking a
picture Philip or records of it it
becomes idiot proof no matter how easy
you think the sandwich is it's still
possible to damage a business on a [__]
sandwich in the past year Phillip has
already changed the menu four times to
no effect so it's not surprising that
Israel needs a little reassurance that
another new menu is the right step if we
agree that we're going to cook it this
way yeah and it changes in and cuts
Corners that is frustrating when I talk
about reintroducing menus I'm not
talking about [__] food that's over
his head I'm talking about soups
sandwiches and straightforward dishes
that you can identify that are idiot
proof and [__] delicious that's music
to my ears that's all but it's not just
the food that's been letting the place
down Dave bone has been a worry to me
ever since I arrived he's talked the
talk but done little to back it up you
have fallen for the um biggest problem
any restaurant manager has with their
staff you become their best mate and
that's pissed off a few people in here
you can't afford to run this restaurant
as your social event otherwise mate you
won't be here for much longer turning
into my own show was probably not the
best of business but the easiest you're
running a [__] smart
cool cafe bar New Start stand apart from
your
staff it's time for a peace Summit
between the war in factions so I've
asked Israel to come up with an exercise
to promote communication and trust
between the kitchen and the front of
house teams you add your onions into it
and you started smashing yeah or mashing
they're going to be making guaca mly but
there's a Twist and the teams
are Phillip you're partnered up with
David the person in the back is actually
making the guaca but you're all going to
be putting a blindfold on so you're
going to have to depend on the person in
front of you directing you I.E we're
going to have to depend on the
restaurant helping the kitchen and the
kitchen helping the restaurant put his
blindfold on if good the head n the neck
B hands behind your back three minutes
starting
from now very very
soft and cut the B next slowly digging
in not Peach a pinch as in a pinch oh
pinch
sorry halfway there eat it m you're
[__] the finger so stop stop
moving yeah
yeah that's me tasting it isra how are
we doing we done give it another mesh
stop was in
front Okay this one
oh it's quite nice but nothing's mhed up
so whose fault was that Monas I guess I
was the one that couldn't see was was
it not
bad nice but there's no Tabasco in there
dve and Phillips
yours were the best thank you very much
I think Dave gave you more encouragement
there in the last 3 minutes than he has
done in two years no matter what happens
from this day on you guys have got to
get on because if the head chef and the
general manager get on then everybody
else underneath you follows suit do you
understand the importance of that we did
quite well start totally start totally
give him a
kiss let's not good that here's the
bonding a happy couple Che Philip and
Dave go on there you go the bonding
Masters one small step for Philip and
Dave but potentially a huge leap for the
business I am never going to put your
finger in my mouth again you put your
finger no yours my finger in your
Jesus by day four Israel's ready to grab
his business by the balls this is his
last roll of the dice honey wants to
start with consistently good fresh food
from the
kitchen Philip with the new potatoes
hone yes nicely
roasted p on tastes very nice it's just
taste
bitter they haven't gone into the fryer
have they no no you sure you haven't put
them in the fryer yep uh look Mister let
me just have a quick word very very
important yeah this this man is paying
your salary yeah his business is about
to close do you understand how critical
the situation is I do so pay the man
[__] respect and tell the truth you
have deep fried those potatoes no these
one haven't been deep fried they are
wrinkled dehydrated and they have been
in the deep fat fryer that's not
dehydrated you're talking to a chef and
for as long as I've got a hole in my
butt big boy those [__] potatoes are
been in the deep fat fryer don't [__]
lie I know what I did you know the
oven's not even hot enough to roast a
potato we can't even cook a [__]
Burger in there they've been in the
fryer tell the [__]
truth look they went in the off okay
tell him the [__]
truth he's so adamant I've even started
to doubt my own judgment until I track
down alema how many trays of potatoes
did you fry this
morning I fried everything here you
fried all four did and who told you to
fry them my chef your Chef yeah why did
you deep fry the
potatoes you you said it earlier it's
because the OV is snowing when you're
hot enough
right can we get back to basics now and
cut the [__]
crap
sorry but I [__] hate
liars it's not rightfully but it's me
who's asking
you yeah the camera forget about the
[__] cam I don't Philip don't you
think that the only reason I'm doing
maybe this programs because this the
last thing that I can do to save the
business I want honesty from you that's
all I want don't be ever ever be scared
of looking like a
pratt but rather be an honest
Pratt than a li of prat cuz then you
lose self-respect my mistake uh I can
only apologize for
this if there's one thing worse than a
chef who can't
cook it's a chef who tells
porkys my workload has just
doubled and there's only one way out of
this cameter coldy sack to get this
place back
online we're going to have to close for
2 days there's no way on Earth we're
ever going to get the food back up the
scratch while you're sending what you're
sending out I need 48 hours we'll work
on Tiding up the dining room painting
and every member of Staff working for
that goal to get it fresh and then two
days in the kitchen to get it on
track how do you feel about it Israel we
can't afford not to take money but we
can't afford not to have a future
business yeah I think something that we
need to stop is a [__] MH I need
people to be honest with me Phillip are
you ready for this if it is to make the
business better I'm I'm a 10% behind
it's not just the Kitchener yeah yeah
but I'm talking about the dining room as
well yeah there's a serious you know
Improvement there to take place it's a
lack of pride a lack of Pride and the
potatoes was the Prime [__] example
cut the [__] you hit the nail on the
[__] head and those that are pulling
on the rope stay and work those that
aren't interested in pulling on the
[__] rope [__]
[Music]
off day five at the place in Essex I've
established the chef is to be kept on a
very short leash and his food is beyond
tragic so for the first time in 4 years
Israel has shut theep place down hello
Michael this Israel P um just you
call with no customers we can throw
everything at revitalizing the
image and most importantly the god awful
menu R whose fault is it really it's
mine and nobody else now it's a fresh
start let's get it back on the road and
very soon will be on the
motorway when a restaurant drastically
changes its food it's important to back
it up with the right
atmosphere a couple of coats of paint is
an easy way to Dazzle your customers and
give you a second chance today is just
about getting the whole place back to
look sharp crisp clean uh and nice and
walk in and say wow yeah I like it the
kitchen's been scrubbed clean and the
oven fixed at
last but that's not all for Phil it
seems all his Noels have come at
once I'm
shaking I'm actually going to have a
kitchen with proper
equipment Israel andara must be bleeding
somewhere this one's going home with me
I'm sleeping with it tonight not
Dave from now on plastic sauces and
frozen foods are Bard per the new menu
will be cooked strictly from fresh
ingredients and our first buy is a 4
kilo ham drizzle the honey and the brown
sugar over it's a delicious steel at a
cost of just £10 and with a little
lateral thinking it's a potential money
spinner this ham how far has it gone
already fried eggs with ham crop mure p
and ham soup can you see just how much
money you can generate from one ham yes
surrounded by all this fresh food
there's a tangible change of energy in
Philip's two young
chefs the seasoning is it's quite even
so it's it's not too
much while M tends the soup ala is
carefully preparing a pot of delicious
bubbl and squeak what do you
think that's a little bit more salt
little bit more salt yeah good I'm glad
you said that M fresh food fresh food m
[__] hell their careers in your
[__] in hands you know you're
supposed to be guiding them through this
you know that yeah how many big chefs
did you work for when you were their age
quite a few yeah and did they kick your
ass oh yes yeah do you hate them for it
I love them for it you love them for it
do you think they love you when you show
them
nothing I think now I'm going to learn
it you've made that from start to finish
before you taste it do you know what I'm
going to do take a [__]
photograph we know Philip that's your
reference yes at last it feels like
we're getting somewhere the shfs are
infused and the dining room has been
transformed almost beyond
recognition but as it stands the outside
of the building is selling all our hard
work short building's beautiful you know
so show it off but we got to get rid of
all the tacky [__] stuck to the front of
it now that you mention it and you see
from a different point of view we go
we're promoting drinks we're saying
cocktail night Thursday night and we go
menu played on a tutty there yeah it's
you're waking up to it and I'm glad
you're starting to open your [__]
eyes because it really is important and
you know the [__] word the place well
you know that's got to go in De bin I
think it's been consensus we going for
um sarin's Cafe Bar yeah [__] perfect
Israel it seems is now on a crusade to
bring the place back from the dead now
get out there and tell the world about
it we've got just one day before the
customers return to a fully booked grand
reopening everything depends on the
kitchen perfecting each and every new
dish on the
menu nice find eggs turn down the gas I
don't want the Yol broken okay they may
be easy peasy but consistent quality
will be the key to ensure repeat
business you have to get in there and
really concentrate yeah this is so
[__] easy the centerpiece for our
menu is going to be the most famous
butty in the world the club sandwich
when I started cooking yeah I had to
make these for a living
every day the
same every day the
same in just 12 hours time the chefs in
the front of house have got to function
as a tight-knit well old
machine chicken avocado salad that's the
H roasted with double fried egg and a
minor miracle has occur which is summon
fish Dave and Philip are
communicating Civ fantastic they all
look really
nice the food is looking 200% better but
to please a lunch hour crowd tomorrow
the grub will have to fly
out are you ready I need to be sure
these boys are really on their toes I'll
do the toast when that goes to 12 we go
go three sandwich quick I'll do the
bread quick quick
quick what are you doing first candles
come on tomorrow we're fully booked for
lunch fully booked Philip is it's not
funny you know that yep I know that Al
anyone talk about putting bacon on who
else is going to put their bacon on oh
yeah
when tonight Al p on coola need a bread
so yes here we go hey presenting to
anyone thought about starting their
french
[Music]
fries guys I get your fries on okay
thank you chef look at the speed of you
fantastically fast is the executive chef
going to come in
last fine no that's his that's yours
there thank you Ali come
on don't quit big boy do not quit you
never ever throw the tal in on service
just come up to the hot plate and
accidentally drop your plate drop it now
drop it oh [__] oh man man Dam [__]
Hey listen all three of you well done
that was [__] excellent yeah the
speed working under pressure and
concentrating was phenomenal and the
best
sandwich is yours
Phillip great without him even knowing
it I've just manag to demote the
executive chef to the club sandwich Chef
now tomorrow we've actually got a chance
of [__] surviving a very busy
lunch 10:00 a.m. launch day with 70
customer has booked in for lunch no one
can afford to be ill prepared I'll be
running checks and checking out the
kitchen all right it's a delicate
balance we've got a new menu are you
ready for this yes big day don't [__] it
up the waiting staff are only just up to
speed and one we link could bring
Israel's last remaining business
tumbling about his
ears I think it'll go well I'm nervous
um cuz everybody's on edge is like up in
a brand new business uh I done before
and I know how disastrous it can be the
first thing I got to say is the place is
defun it's gone yeah welcome to Us's
Cafe Bar yes we work together as a team
we understand each other yeah there's
going to be several customers that are
going to be going for a 30 minute lunch
that's a soup and a sandwich a soup and
a salad whatever they prefer within 30
minutes I can guarantee if they leave
under 30 minutes they'll be back next
week three or four times between Monday
and Friday get it right yeah this is it
without you I can't do it consistency
ala Bingo new order two tomato soup two
sandwiches that's the the quick deal
yeah 30 minutes yeah well tell the
Brigade The Lunch deal is cheap at just
£650 is the bacon on for the tub
sandwich is the toasting it's going in
now to make it worth his Ra's while Dave
must fill the restaurant twice over
which means turning the tables fast
super sandwich this has to go like clock
me three minutes three more minutes
excellent good um two seconds Philip
Philip Philip thank you yeah what's that
in there a new
potato where did that come
from I know we got to push it out and
move our ass but we're not going to
serve that like that what's
burning turn it over medium [__] up
we've been over this menu time and time
again but Mon and ala are already
buckling under the pressure ham and eggs
how [__] difficult is that that you
burst the Yol yeah it's a customer's
privilege to burst their own [__] Yol
not you yes and there's only three
orders on breast the lettuce Mon and
vinegarette on there Welsh rabbits all
pissing over the plate
Che by 12:30 the restrooms full to
bursting do we have lacing l no it's all
done to the kitchen now one more club
sandwich another three bread enough
another burger with chips and big beans
service please service please where's
the rest of the fish to I said to take
some out of the freeer it seems my super
basic menu Isn't basic enough for this
team of nums they're not cooked they are
no they're not cooked look m m the
burner and the deep fat fryer has gone
out the and they've been trying to cook
chips in cold
[Music]
oil no wonder but you can't let one
problem bring the whole operation to its
knees no we just friy the potato wedgies
in a pan
though huh yeah almost like a roast
potato all together six soup the orders
are stacking up and the Panic has
already set in call this new ERS can I
have some grass on this soup please you
mean CH yeah just give me the freaking
grass that's thank you and now there's a
problem with the tickets
table
five table five I don't have I've got
three all the communication has gone out
the window and the customers are left in
the dark as to why their food is taking
so long we have an hour for lunch so
obviously we have to try and fit the
food in within the hour so I've just had
to phone the office and tell them we're
going to be a bit late get back to work
in 10 minutes
those that are getting their food are
loving it but 20 minutes later there's
no resolve to the ticket confusion the
ticket's gone disapp that's why there's
such a problem because they've been
waiting ABS ages and
nobody's Phil's only guidance through
this mess are his tickets but it seems
everyone's had their hands on them I
don't have the ticket back and if a chef
loses an order it's like an air traffic
controller losing a plane Dave took it
he didn't bring back one Reby rare one
and this one's going down fast AOC hold
on come here come here what's what's
going on why is it food coming back turn
around I got a table s here that you're
giving me that was gone a long time ago
so we've already sent the table oh come
on right now we don't need to [__]
repeat the
order huh that's because the waiter
leaves the order don't blame don't put
it on the pick no very s I'm going for a
cigarette I had it this sh what do you
mean you're going out for a cigarette
well sink I had enough of this [__] yeah
but we're sinking you can't just
disappear there is enough okay when
somebody does a mistake I'm the first to
admit it but not when I'm covering for
someone else's [__] well you don't I had
enough of
this you can't just walk out for a
cigarette Philip I'm sorry the shit's
hit the fan I'm here to
help let's get back on here straight
away and start again let's go come on it
seems Israel believes Philip's not
entirely to blame for this Fiasco why do
I have a waitress going into the kitchen
with a problem without they knowing
you've been told there is a manager on
the floor and that manager should be on
the ball with every single [__] table
what stage are they have they have a
coffee have they had to drink how long
since they order there that's what I
want out of it stops here it has to stop
there yeah exactly that I was wrong
Israel's
right as a manager Dave should have the
situation well in hand you been in
charge of cing the food in and out you
need to know what stage it's going hang
on hang on let me finish okay get off
the floor now yeah get off the floor now
okay get off the floor now
fine use the back door please the
catalog of disasters has taken their
toll Israel's had to give away over100
worth of complimentary food and drink
and to avoid further embarrassment is
decided to shut the service down after
just one sitting how long for table for
Philip do you know how long they've been
in here I can imagine 1 hour 20 [__]
minutes 1 hour and 20
minutes what the [__] going to happen
Saturday
well tomorrow we're going to have to get
our ship together that's for sure it's
been a real disappointment for everyone
but we can learn from today's harsh
lessons may I suggest you know only take
the customers you can do and then each
and every day build it because
chanceford is a small close-knit town
and if word spreads that you've reopened
and the food's not as good as you think
it should be then they won't come back H
Phil's clearly been through the mill
these last few days even though I didn't
want to admit it I have actually lost
part of that passion which I had doesn't
it become painful trying to cook with no
feeling becomes an automatism MH will
you find that passion again it has come
back already mhm well I didn't think
that lunch time when you walked out for
a cigarette but you came back that was
the most important thing you know that
yeah and I appreciated that yeah hey I
don't want to do it without
you it's not my kitchen yeah know this
is your kitchen I know yeah perhaps one
of the toughest weeks I've ever had in
my [__] career oh yeah oh [__] yeah
definitely but get it back cont track
that's the most important thing Israel
keep on them yeah breathing down their
necks yeah thank you very much bye thank
you bye Care thank you Gordon thank you
guys Chef thank you yes do you really
hate
me can I pass on the
comments bye guys yes hey you I'll be
back thank you I'll be back yes good
with when you say
Bye by
byebye
oh can breathe
that it's been 6 weeks since I was last
in chelsford and I've heard rumors that
something strange has been going on at
the sarson's head Cafe
Bar what happened to sarson's head in
the week I spent at D place it didn't
take long to sus out that D stood for
Dreadful and for as long as I've got a
hole in my butt big boy those [__]
potatoes have been in the deep fat fryer
the owners were in Dire Straits if I
don't do something drastic then you know
this business will go down the pan and
the staff were dysfunctional from now on
stop being a stubborn [__] French
bastard we need to turn their attitudes
around and [__] get this place back
on track over the longest seven days of
my life we injected some passion into
the food no that's his that's yours
there come
on and got the team eating out of each
other's hands that that's me tasting it
it wasn't perfect got to get back to
work in 10 minutes but I really felt
that sar's cafe bar was well on the road
to recovery all three of you well done
that was [__]
excellent the latest news from inside is
is unbelievable I thought things
couldn't get any worse but they just
have um God how strange I mean really
really strange um Israel is no longer
there the place has gone into
receivership she said two weeks ago it
doesn't belong to him the brewery have
taken it back and um he's been kicked
out the Brewer has put the lease of the
place up for sale and Israel and Tara
are out on their ears ironically the one
person I suspected might not be here is
here Philip
executive chef extraordinaire it's it's
a very very sad you know uh story total
total shock yeah and everything you put
into it and what the guys done and just
yeah all gone down the drain basically
you looking very clean obviously not
making many club
sandwiches the time down we are it's one
of the best sell what better than the
cro M show no come on it is better a
better salad than the what's coming out
the quickest
the club sandwich the club
sandwich so it appears that things were
really starting to happen at the place
after I left and the food sales were on
the up hello Israel hello I did not
expect to see you here you know that but
it seems it was too little too late for
Israel and
Tara oh [__] yeah very well how are you
feeling all right thank yeah yeah yeah
we all last chance to get it to get it
together and we did the town was bassing
with with sarson's head being able to
produce the quality of the food that we
were producing nice simple the people
were coming in and said it was delicious
it was perfect they didn't have long to
reap the benefits shortly after I left
the brewery took the business out of
Israel and Tara's hands and it just
happened on the spur of the moment that
you're at work and all of a sudden bang
well we were we didn't even know we were
going to be asked for the keys just
bought a new house
mortgage all at the wrong time you're
out yeah on your ass you're s months
pregnant eight months pregnant eight
months pregnant I mean this is not the
kind of predicament I you know I
expected to see um what did you lose is
I lost obviously more than I did but
mine was inheritance from my mother and
my grandmother the fact that I was naive
and I didn't know how Corporate big
Nationals work and and and the world of
the accountants and the solicitors and
all of that crap I don't know anything
about I know how to serve people I know
how to make them smile I know how to
deal with a complaint I know how to deal
with the kitchen I don't know how to
deal with business you know transactions
of that matter no and that's where it
hurts love you and leave you I feel so
sorry for them and I still can't quite
believe what's happened good luck the
baby take care Israel and Tara had
genuinely thought they could keep the
business going but sadly after calling
the spokesperson for the brewery It all
becomes crystal clear okay all right
thank you
Tim um sounds now like the brewery were
only acting on their best interest by
accepting the highest bid and I think
Israel has been slightly naive no matter
how good the food is you've really got
to understand every aspect of your
business and the areas you don't
understand seek
advice before you get
[Music]
[__] 6 and 1 half minutes
that's not bad does it taste as good as
it
looks very nice you have got your
passion back you know that that is
[__] delicious
[Music]
ma mamerry Soul Food shack has hit rock
bottom we have put so much of our own
own money in it and on it we no longer
have it the customers just aren't biting
10 1 Saturday lunchtime and this place
should be absolutely round there's too
many cooks doing all the wrong
things oh [__] now if you turn up for
work half an hour late in my kitchen
you'd be home for the day looking for a
new [__] job turn this into a
professional outfit within a week that
would take a miracle I've definitely
gone wo
it's time to get serious and if you
don't break away from this stove I swear
to God the business is going to close
you need young man I [__] rocket up
your ass I'm not going to lose my
business Brighton London by the Sea
loads of locals and a steady stream of
hungry
tourists nesting just a stone throw away
from the seafront is Mama sher's sold
Food Shack offering Classics from
America's Deep South oh nice nice nice
the big Soul Mama AKA Sharita Jones has
raised 33 foster children but running
her first restaurant is proving a far
bigger handful it's all going to just
kind of go and fall apart so I don't
want it to fall apart God it's
definitely a Shack on the outside anyway
[__] up
Caravan is this
[Music]
it Sharita Sharita Gordon good to see
you nice to see you this is small and qu
welome it's quaint it's cozy I'll say
it's like walking it's like walking into
your front Lounge thank you and that's
what it's supposed to be about because I
tend to spend all my life here this has
got to be my front room otherwise when
do I get to kick my feet up after 3 and
a half years despite throwing everything
at this place and working 7 days a week
Sharita is still in serious debt to the
tune of £65,000
and who's the chef I'm kind of the chef
I come from a background of big mamas
and all of them cook it's called stick
to your ribs basically stick to your
roots ribs oh Ribs Right see your roots
see your ribs Mama Sher Shack seats 40
at an extremely intimate
squeeze I am notan but sadly for shita
that's not often a problem as weekday
trade is virtually nonexistent it's
great at the weekends but somehow we've
discovered that we're in a hole we're
just in this hole a financial hole that
we can't claw our way out of have you
made any money since you've been open
nope not a penny not a single penny have
we made since we've been open it's hard
to put our finger on why is it critical
I mean how long how long can you
continue you stay like this truthfully
truthfully I'd
say 3 to 6 months maximum maximum so I
can no customers no money right it's
time to check out the kitchen God
Sharita calls herself the cook but Brian
moyo is her head chef so who's in
charge how you doing dude thank you did
you do this and all that and Poland uh I
try not
to we either go for cliche
so are you the head chef or you the cook
what are you um I'm confused well I I
was employed to Come As a head chef but
because of uh problems with finances and
things like that so don't let me stop
you I took a a sit back so who who
writes the menu uh shita has written
everything she does everything basically
she got a cushy job then really haven't
you you could say that as a chef yes
pretty
chill yeah as a chef yes is pretty sh
but a head chef who doesn't write the
menu and only works 35 hours a week
next he'll be telling me he's forgotten
how to cook here you go we got some
catfish gons with Hush Puppy and our
homemade pineapple
salsa it's actually quite nice very um
very delicate fish and um it's nicely
fried very light really nice thank you
be back with your Ms sh it down my mom
make is my God for ma my plates piled
high with a clumsy mess of ribs spicy
chicken jumbal and corn and bean sucker
tach I hope he likes
it [__] now there
ribs so
tender I have to say it's thr on the
plate with no real care but it tastes
phenomenal this may be the first time I
actually go back to the kitchen with an
empty
plate um thank you bloody delicious
thank you and you know whatk you I
thought it was going to be really spicy
but just turned down and it was spot on
and it actually made me feel like I was
back at Mom's for the first time oh and
having some home cooking it was very
good don't get me
crying there are things I would change
okay and I'm happy I'm happy to hear
about that I can't take a picture of
this
I know it sounds crazy I know it sounds
crazy M your head mine your head oh God
I fed good
ramsy and he cleaned his place how the
hell did you turn that thing off she
doesn't shut up rabbit rabbit rabbit
rabbit rabbit rabbit [__] sherita's down
home style should be a unique selling
point but it ain't
working I need to go back to the kitchen
and find out why
Friday and Sharita is tackling most of
the day's preparation single-handedly in
a desperate bid to save money part of
this is you know you've got to get your
hands dirty I'm concerned marinating
meat making dressings sauces and bacon
are all crucial things to prepare in
advance of a busy service and it's just
shaking off the excess but deep frying
chicken wings 8 hours in advance of
their first booking that can't be
right just leave so why would you cook
them now because if you cook them off
now and leave them to cool when the
order comes in it's just a matter of
picking out how many we need and they go
back in and they come back up to a nice
and they don't go try no no I'm
beginning to suspect the good old home
cooking isn't as wholesome as it could
be they smell
good most of it's coming from the
freezer rather than the so to much so
how many freezers have we got 13 13
freezing Freez [__] me by the time Brian
turns up there's not much left for him
to do so you can't really feel like a a
chef if you've got shita in the kitchen
every morning cooking the food and you
come in saying send it in a sense you're
not actually really cooking you're just
coming in and putting things together
putting your things together yes it's
kind of hard yes have you lost
motivation
yes so if sherita's head Chef's gone off
the boil I'm hoping her remaining crew
of part-timers have a bit more
spunk heading up front of house is
Lauren she arrives 10 minutes late for
the evening
service 20-year-old ad seems to be more
committed to his glamorous day job so
why penel beating uh night just finish
at all four every day kitchen Porter
Gavin lives next door but he appears to
turn up when he feels like
it and sherita's librarian husband Phil
hot foots it back from the day job to
become basement Barman and resident DJ
he looks like you're washer uper no way
I he does that as
well these and numerous other part-time
staff are all members of M sher's big
laidback family so when he's in the ship
in middle of service he slid them down
like [__] Michael Jackson
yes oh [__]
now I hate to ruin a good party but if
you want to run a successful business
then the terms laidback and professional
just don't mix it's not just about how
good the food tastes it's about how it
[__] gets there as well and that is
crucial I can't wait to see this team of
jokers in
action all right so we get going cuz
they're hungry immediately it's clear
who's the mummer in this kitchen I'm
getting you a chili pepper cuz you ain't
you no just the
one can I take the seeds out at least
shita talks to them like they're her
children and she's the only one cooking
anything from fresh I need to start
cooking up these toit now okay Sharita
all of the second uh party you're in all
right okay two potato skins onion RS
cornbread two pieces can I get some
jumble heated up please for Brian and 0
it's just an elaborate Heating and
plating up exercise mountains of messy
food School dinner style a D minus must
try harder that's hot gravy yeah on hot
turkey y served on cold plates y with
cold salad
yep what's he laughing at
this is serious you weren't going to
break sweat there were you oh you w he's
about to kick off
when there's twice as many STS as there
need
be this should be an absolute
Breeze but she just killing herself
trying to do everything we got
everything in the basement yeah
everything's
[Music]
gone [__] paying two fully qualified
chefs to dress and send a PL of nachos
come on that's a sure fine way to break
a business [__] that was painful very
very painful tonight on several
occasions you're standing here cooking
away in a world of your own yeah and
these guys standing there just almost
playing with themselves because they're
waiting for something from you if you
are the head chef yes then you're going
to have to start taking the reins yeah
yeah I want to try and get through a
busy night without pissing your pants
with Laughter 2 hours has pure
concentration without laughing okay and
I bet you can't do it I can do it you're
[__] smiling
already if there was ever a case of too
many cooks this is it one of them will
have to go [__] already I said no
smiling no laughing serious okay set a
[__] example and do not be scared to
get rid of
baggage
Brighton's best kept secret Mamer Soul
Food shack is so well kept it's losing
,000 a week no one here 20 10 in the
morning no by day three I've uncovered a
couple of reasons why I know it's
chilled but [__] hell not as chilled
as a snapper why is no one here this
time in the morning it's ridiculous
firstly the food's good but it could be
so much better where's uh where's Brian
let me give you a hand Brian yeah I have
no idea you should be secondly there are
far too many staff and most of them
aren't pulling their
weight late this morning yes half an
hour what' you do to him when he's late
nothing nothing I'm just going to wash
up right now so you're washing up as
well she's in she opens up brings all
the supplies upstairs you should be
ashamed of yourself
ran sh's next task is to make a huge
batch of macaroni cheese that will last
her for two whole weeks keep this going
a this is coming up nicely
hot from the stove her food is
irresistible people will travel miles to
taste it do you think I like that yeah
yeah very nice but like a lot of our
home cooking this lot is destined for
the freezer where its delicious texture
and flavor will be lost
forever well you cook beautifully yeah
and I don't understand why you want to
freeze it when it's so tasty well I well
I think I don't think I want it's not a
case of wanting no I think you've got
into a habit I've got in a habit which
is a lazy habit you're not lazy cuz you
work so bloody hard he's lazy it's a
matter of he's definitely lazy if you
turn up for work half an hour late in my
kitchen trust me you'd be home for the
day looking for a new [__]
job to be honest it's no wonder Brian's
lost heart the man's been working in the
kitchen for as long as I have but to
save money he's been sidelined I was
gone by so much so he's rarely involved
in actually making any of the food there
is a kind of a method to my madness but
you're throwing it together
um it looks like I'm throwing it
together but I throw it together the
exact same way every single week so when
you're not doing it who does it I'm
doing it that's my point okay if shita
was using Brian properly they could
ditch the freezers once and for all and
the macaroni and cheese is nearly there
that looks delicious I think that should
go to sta food yeah I think so does look
good doesn't it as it stands few
customers will taste the food at its
best she has thrown away her unique
selling point
[Music]
and boy does she need
one it's uh 10 1 Saturday lunchtime and
this place should be absolutely round
and there's not a soul in
[Music]
here this is D Saturday and Sunday are
your Prime days for business but like
many failing restaurants shita is making
some classic mistakes Poor Man's meat
pie yeah £8 yeah I know it's going to be
good M it is yeah you go on the menu
here you've got main courses at 14 yeah5
mhm why they gone up so expensive um to
pay my bills M to be blunt it bank
manager yeah um accountant and I was
saying help me help me how do I do this
they say you only you got to raise your
prices you got to raise your prices
always the bank manager's solution put
your prices and it was it was literally
down to the bank manager well he's an
[__] oh good yeah it's killing the
business I want to look at restructuring
the menu making it a little bit shorter
okay tweaking the portion size all right
having less come back 60% or bones come
back but it's that 40% on want to work
on the objective for every customer come
through that door is to have a starter a
Ms and a dessert okay you wait and see
the turnover treble if you can squeeze
three cses out of them okay
but before we can squeeze anything out
of anybody we need
customers and if they're not coming to
us we've got to take Mama sher's finger
licking food to them so got the meatloaf
oh my God got the ribs okay got the
chicken that smells amazing oh was
smelling so good so good and who better
to flaunt it than the mama herself don't
be shy whoa I'm going to come to you
since you're not coming to me
this is all cooked freshh at Mama Cherry
Soul F Shack just around the corner
there pretty good this particular food
is called soul food okay cooked from the
soul from the
heart boy she's good a soul food
evangelist and she's out to convert the
whole of Brighton soul food can I hear
you all say it soul food right just wind
her up and let her go that's it Give Me
Wings all right get this time it's on
the house next time they're paying you
yeah did you cook yes I did love
it there's no doubt that shita is a
terrific cook but she's employing Brian
to do that job and I'm beginning to
realize she's wasted in the
kitchen what's it
called just call me Mama thank you Mama
you got
it with Saturday night service about to
begin it's time to get this Shack in
order it's pretty obvious
that the business is in D straights you
know that's real it's real that's the
truth yes it is watching you guys over
the last couple of days you actually
treat it like it's your [__] home
chilled relaxed and this lady here you
talk her almost as if it's your
mom MH and that really has to stop if
this is going to go any further and if
it doesn't work not only you're out of
business and your livelihoods gone all
of you guys are out of a [__] job
you've got no work so when it's that far
down we really have to dig deep and come
up with sensible ideas and tonight I'm
going to ask you to stay out the kitchen
okay you've got so much to sell yeah and
you you're a [__] good cook thank you
so shita let him cook I'm going to let
him I'm going to let him I am you have
to pass the RS over now and if you don't
break away from the stove mhm I swear to
God the business is going to close and
let them do the job that you [__] pay
the money for okay yeah yep I'm going to
go put some makeup on cuz I'm going
downstairs shita Street hustling has
secured a full book restroom tonight if
we're going to get through it we need to
get this kitchen working like an
efficient well oiled machine you doing
the Fant Time to whip up a bit of
professionalism into these boys gav can
you tell those starters and food
downstairs yeah standing there do
nothing five there you go five thank you
can we standing there open up your eyes
yeah and get him [__] working okay
you're running this place tonight you
know that I'm going to prove to her
downstairs that you can do it and not
just to her but to yourself and me I
said no smiling no laughing serious okay
yes yeah let's
go she still smiling now good evening
have you had a chance to look at the
menu yeah downstairs shita slip
effortlessly into the role of the
hostess with the mostess any of you eat
macaroni and
cheese I'm telling it's
fantastic C graded my
cheese Brian's taking his first decision
as a head chef pre-cooked buffalo wings
are off the menu from now on they're
being cooked to order chicken been
cooked from
fresh nice you already Place turned
around in 20 minutes well almost the
rest of the food's going out just as
sherita's always done it hot food cold
plates and inspiring
salads for that that's shocking and your
breaking meatloaf
close you laugh um but let's not try to
run before we can walk can I get this
one as soon as
[Music]
possible how long give time 3 minutes 3
minutes there we are I'll take that
thank you bye okay see you all right
there you go up the restaurant's full
but now she's front of house she is
using every trick in the book to boost
business 5 minutes you go right next
door to my friendly Club there you go
and I will well see you in five see you
in five thank you okay thank you
okay Brian move 2 hours in and the
food's not going out quick enough
sherita's faith in Brian is dwindling
fast these guys have been in a long time
I got kids down there yeah but the
starters have just gone starters okay
what happened there those starters those
starters they done so already in the
left yeah yeah they Ed what these St
what for table these ones no I'm doing
them now oh [__] I just told that
they're gone man for Brian 3 years of
living in the conary coma is a hard
habit to break he's beginning to lose
it five other tables still waiting on
their
starters and sherita's constant
interruptions aren't exactly helping
come on Brian don't lose it now yet no
what else on this table I need to see
what's on it got you got hot wings and
barbecue chicken wings I've got the hot
wings I need whatever else is there cuz
they are getting
restless oh
dear all they
order that's it send it
away I am so sorry I'll tell you what
the problem was with fresh food yeah you
can't expect the food to just jump on
your plate just like that we can explain
that to her after chicken takes a good
14 20 minutes to make sure that you know
you don't kill anyone okay has that pig
feet go on cuz it needs to go or now cuz
it takes the time yeah every minute
you're in here we're losing
money [__]
hell so what do you think of that meat
Lo good thank you didn't I tell you
didn't I tell you I thought the kitchen
go a really good start you were slightly
nervous being down there because you
were sort of not spying on them but
coming up agitated yeah you lost it
Brian a little bit yes a little bit and
things just got a little bit on top you
said something interesting though yeah
TR has to understand it's going to take
3 or 4 minutes longer because I'm
cooking from raw and the benefit is the
customer but I think this guy yeah with
the help of AD can get faster much much
faster I mean how would you sum up you
were in the dining room tonight it felt
good because I'm telling you for three
and a half years being here it was the
first Saturday night that I have spent
downstairs they've seen you you know
that's the face they want to see when
they come they see Mama downstairs I'm
going to be cracking the whip a lot
harder it's your business of course you
know and that's what I was thinking
you know I got to crack it let's go okay
thank you good thank you guys let me go
down here and finish seeing cuz I got a
few more desserts to sell
y if Brian's going to win sherita's
respect as her head chef he needs to
become more involved in preparing the
food as well as cooking it number 13
lucky for some but since his SS were cut
he's been dropped in a catch 22
situation where's little lady on hey
Brian's been left holding the baby it
became a problem because CLA had to go
to work yeah and uh we had to find a way
of meeting uh the the bill at the end of
the month yeah you know and that's why
uh I can't to do Tuesdays and Wednesdays
the whole thing is just confused yeah
you know as Brian's involvement with the
food has diminished so too has his
confidence the first time he made
meatloaf 2 years ago it was a disaster
so we're going to prove that Brian can
not only do it but do it better but how
much influence do you have on the menu
even sometimes I do a menu or something
but she changes it anyway so really at
the end of the day my influence
disappears but you've got to be strong
now CU she's going to concentrate in the
dining room you're going to be running
the kitchen you have to be strong yes
huh
yes the problem with sherita's meatloaf
is the bacon by the time it's cooked
it's like cutting into
leather the back bacon you saw dries out
there hardly any fat in back bacon so
you streaky bacon um Place one nice
fatty piece of bacon there as it's
cooking yeah it's putting moisture
exactly inside the meat lifea yeah
fantastic you know if if I put my foot
down and say no this is like this like
that I think I can see myself going far
you know I can achieve
things it's a it's a healthy feeling you
know it's a healthy
feeling M just look at
them
the seasoning is just right it's not too
saly just I think that's fine doesn't
need any doesn't need anything else
anything else at
all with Brian's confidence slowly
returning now I've got to work on
Sharita she excels as a natural cook and
a great hostess oh my God that's
everything on my menu shita but when it
comes to business she's a self-confessed
num SK yeah one2 me long and this tells
me the money the money is look how
that's a bit shorter Shor yeah we want
it the other way around I want it the
other way around definitely but it's not
just the Takens that are the problem
here okay 200 g of butter right yeah
like a beautifully risen cake successful
rests only Thrive when three key
business factors are working in close
harmony gradually add 200 g of flour we
established one3 staff cost one3 food
cost and one3 gross profit
combine all those ingredients into one
recipe yeah chemistry you have the most
amazing cake and that's how any good
business works yeah at the moment sh's
business cake is way off course I'm
going to show you something what we've
got currently happening here at the sh
with few midweek customers Sha's gross
profits are dangerously low very very
little profit her food costs are
reasonably healthy but her massive
overheads are crippling
her show what's going to cost you when
we start adding really high staff costs
so there's an imbalance already oh God
yep bloody hard now I'm doing this on
purpose to prove a point y y yeah you
can't complete a recipe for a successful
business when you got imbalanced
situation you can tell me to [__] off
but how much do you pay yourself a month
i p a month
uh about well I get around 200 a week
that's it I'm the lowest out of the
kitchen £200 a week a week yeah 800 a
month month you're working seven days a
week I'm working seven days a week
that's a [__] disgrace i 0 gets more
than me some weeks a Comm Chef that's
part-time gets paid more than you MH
you're far too [__]
soft I know I know you really are far
too soft well it stops now I know I know
I know I know I know I
know that is a profitable business with
the right ingredients uhhuh yeah that is
what you're currently running right have
a think and let me know which one you'd
like to
eat very good oh I just feel like
[Applause]
crying why are you crying
Sharita cuz I'm not going to lose my
business
[Music]
I'm nearing the end of my week in
Brighton a [__] bollocks not sure I
found my soul yet but Brian is finally
beginning to behave like a head
[Music]
chef and Sharita is undergoing a
transformation from mother to matron and
from now on she'll be ruling this Roost
with an iron hand this is not a drop in
center but we still have a fundamental
problem a crippling lack of weekday
customers what we need is a gimmick a
bargain that will ensure the Shacks full
to the rafters all week long the idea is
is to sell uhhuh your restaurant per
table okay okay so table of six uhhuh
six jaars y £10 ahead uhhuh £0 for that
table if that worked yeah every night
at10 ahead yeah that's 360 in the till
think of it this way yeah they'll spend
the same amount of money on their
alcohol on
alcohol my plan is to create an exciting
three course fixed buffet for each table
simplifying the service and cherry
picking from the existing menu okay but
before we do the big presentation to
Sharita I've got to inject some life
into those God awful limp
salads how much does sal cost in the
menu 450 £4 [__] 50 huh do you think
that's real good value for money what
you're serving not really no no made a
very simple dressing here roasted cumin
yes yeah little bit of olive oil MH
fresh lime uhuh okay look at the
difference now and start building it up
and get some colors in there yeah £450
for a salad it's a [__] joke um sweet
potatoes uh huge in Soul Food yeah all
they've done is been blanched into the
pan yeah nicely colored don't move them
until they got color on there okay cuz
the more you move them around what
happens they break up they break up that
voice in the background she's in the
kitchen again and Lady the secret here
now is to keep them nice and hot they go
really almost like a roast potato this
is not a difficult finicky thing to do
for me you know when you look at the
style of sh's food it's really important
to keep it rustic don't want anything
fancy I'm not being funny but Gavin the
kitchen Porter can get this stuff done
yes
huh oh that is good d
I'm in heaven what I'm trying to do is
make the plates look less cluttered yes
I understand the food speaks for itself
and sometimes I see these mountains of
food going out okay and you know it's
it's too much come here here you go lick
it oh and you know you'll want
to what can I say cousin golden sweet
potato salad yeah yeah that's what it's
going to be called mix in I canot mix it
doing that that was better actually I
did just Chef seriously Che no more food
piled high on cold plates okay I want to
get these bowls C up at £1 ahead as long
as it's delicious and looks good the
customers are going to love it we can
present going there chicken
chickeni Brian can clear the Frozen
backlog and start from fresh make it
look nice yeah we got to sell this you
yeah got to really sell
[Music]
it simple sexy and irresistible soul
food m
as well come on then do it do
something you driving around the B you
know that Ed what do you think table of
four [__] huh [__]
good every day this is fantastic
honestly what leftovers what you can do
let's go [__]
hell right charita basically we've gone
through the fridge see what need be used
up yes um and every day is going to
change yes here we just made a really
nice uh vegetable um pigil and it just
marinades through brown sugar and
vinegar look at that there for four
people yeah you got a muger soup as well
don't forget I think it's quite sort of
fresh and new yeah and it sort of
deformalization
this they come back Friday or Saturday
for a full thing yeah yeah this looks
great good mhm I like this tomorrow
we're going live oh don't worry I'm
going to be now you said live you wait
I'm going to be
live it seems shita is well and truly
sold on our new idea W okay I just got
to think of a word for tapers I'm going
to come up with my own word I'mma make a
word up but I guess I can't call it
slapers cuz that sounds too rude
[Music]
and short Dynamic St to the point yeah
the Mama's on a crusade right custom
okay customers so in a bowl all right
and we're launching tomorrow evening
having a big party down there 10 lb each
three courses delicious oh my EXC okay
I'm doing ribs jumalia barbecue chicken
going brown bring bring some friends
with you okay you love the food
fantastic by tomorrow night sharid wants
the whole of West Sussex to know about
Mama sher's this is Southern FM that's
six the best nonstop wrapping up with
the house Martin's happy hour Thor in my
side with me and it's brand new midweek
eating concept so in the bowl come nikk
give me some of this this is ribs okay
here we go yeah gorgeous absolutely
lovely you eat I'll talk okay when
you're hungry and you need of a serious
food attack just come to Mama cherri's
the Soul Food shack we've got soul in a
bowl three yummy courses is served on a
platter fried chicken jumbalaya and more
we're talking Soul Food tappers the
price is so right so come to the shack
tonight for meable see as you brought us
breakfast you going have that huge plug
for nothing thank
you thank you breakfast was delicious on
a normal Wednesday night shita would be
lucky to get eight
customers good morning Mama Cher's going
to help you but whilst we've been out
bookings for this evening's launch have
gone through the roof early oh l doing
probably two sittings a 7:00 and a 9:00
sitting it's all coming together except
for One Small
Hitch there's no Brian there's no ad
there's no Gavin no one's here Brian's
stuck with a [__] babysitter
somewhere God knows where and um you
know what if they're ever going to get
this place right then they're going to
have to really understand discipline
because this is a joke big day no one in
the [__]
kitchen where have you been looking for
very C Chef looking for come on can get
changed yeah I thought we going to be
here by 10:00 I was meant to be at 10:
but uh I tried to find the girl who
looked after them yesterday yeah she
said no go just like that out of the
blue get changed yeah and let's get
[__] started yeah let's go yeah I was
hoping the renewed responsibility of
running this kitchen would reight
Brian's passion for cooking you need
young man eggs a [__] rocket up your
ass and with it bring a new commitment
to both raising the quality and the
urgency with which the food's delivered
how about sweating off the onions at the
same time they're in front ofly there
look oh okay there you
go but even if Brian was making the new
improved meatloaf twice as fast [__]
useless it still wouldn't be quick
enough I'm just testing it now to see
what uh flavors have come up yeah but
you haven't put the wet mixture in there
yet so how can you identify the texture
oh
yes get the recipe complete first add
the bread crumb then do the [__]
test
Jesus Christ some mothers do have
them and I've got
one thankfully sh is completely unaware
that Brian's already losing it
upstairs so how's it looking now um it's
looking full the day of the week or may
Wednesday this is wonderful perfect and
50 55 customers tonight that's £550 on
food y the same again yep hopefully on
the drink drink that's £1,000 in the
tail which is equivalent to a Friday
night yeah yeah that's a Friday night a
touch of flexibility it's a new start
for the Sha and tonight every member of
shita Staff has got to give 100% okay
here are a set of rules that each and
every one of you are now going to abide
by and it's not a governing rule it's an
understanding what this business needs
to go further and forward I need
everybody here on time and on time means
if I say you start at 600 you get here
at quarter two that way you have your
cigarettes you get changed you chat you
have your coffee and so that at 6:00
you're on the floor okay the next one is
there is always something to do if you
can't think of it ask me the queen is
now in Residence yes shita is now on the
floor y that's where I'm going to be and
to confirm that we're going to raise the
flag yes all right okay okay Sharita is
in residance yes and that's where she
stays I want you to pull this up here
together there you go listen have a
great service think customer push the
wine and work together let's get it
right right [__] now let's go okay
inside your chable here the success of
soul in a bowl relies on do in large
numbers and only10 ahead shita must fill
the restaurant twice over everything's
prep yes are you nervous yeah I am good
it's a good sign start [__] yourself
Brian ad and Gavin I've got to get those
platters flying down those stairs but
they're only just peeling the last
potatoes we're going to send you down a
tray designed for to it comes with
cornbread and soup as a starter soup's
excellent I hope you enjoy it I think
you will very much all right
unfortunately we are
fully it's the first Wednesday night
ever they've had to turn customers away
slightly spicy sweet potato table three
two meat T okay just to bring them up to
the
m table seven that you've got up there
it's down is three they've had a person
join them so it's now for It's already
looking better but tonight it's got to
be perfect stop stop take the [__]
Bowl off the tray put it in the bowl
yeah I don't want all the [__] on there
everywhere yeah I want nice and
clean [__] clean come on yeah and for
the first time this week Brian's not
smiling that looks lovely Well Done
Right vegetarian please Eddie send it
away so now we're looking for a four
soup and a three soup four cornbread
three cornbread Gavin you're taking care
of of the desserts yeah
chicken the team is pulling together can
you put a small just bowl of Veggie
jambalaya on it and then the big one is
going to have the meat come on going to
PP if we slow down I'm going to lose it
communication is much much better can I
get a timing on some of these I can tell
them 5 minutes 5 minutes on all of them
okay here we go ads at 8: so far so good
yeah doing a good job if they can keep
it going we might just pull this one off
they said they are stuffed it was
delicious all of the different flavors
that go with it fully satisfied I'm
going to take them some dessert you see
that empty
bowls and for that dessert a surprised
us all with his homemade peac and pies
that is delicious that beat panel
beating any day you know that any day at
just 40 P to make each slice it's a
fifth Che cheaper and 10 times tastier
than the ones Sharita has been buying in
how was the soup good yeah all right
things must be going okay because we've
hardly seen her in the kitchen all night
are we starting to turn the tables now
I'm starting to turn but I've got to get
this is a crucial thing at1 ahead we
have to turn those so can we do two TRS
at the same time is it possible can yeah
now the pressure's really on we're
losing come on let's get some
organization guys come on it's still not
perfect a table's called away you stick
that ticket on the tray no one touches
it but the vibe up here has definitely
got more professional we're losing
valuable time man what are you doing we
2 minutes over how's it feeling up here
hot H all right can't quite believe I'm
saying this but I think Brian's actually
breaking a sweat guys looking good
they're loving it people are loving it
very tasty very good food you got the
salads well done man thank you thank you
I haven't eaten anything quite like this
before and it's really nice okay what
waiting is a two a six and a four then
we'll
finish you couldn't get better value for
money than this it's it's it's
remarkable let's get it going last table
goes out just like the first table
yes oh we'll come back definitely
definitely we come back nice
beautiful [__] well done yeah really
good that's one day the real work starts
tomorrow yeah yeah let's go I didn't
know how much I was going to cook today
you know I didn't know if I was going to
cook or break basically but I just one
thought of my mind is to get through
[Music]
this Thursday morning and the whole team
are in
early you got to get that well
going they're clean out of food stocks
and fully book tonight so they're
starting completely from
[Music]
scratch fresh home cooking Straight From
the Soul
Hallelujah can I just say you set me a
Target when I spoke to you last night we
hadn't reached that Target £800 last
night I asked for 1,000 when I cashed up
I hit 1,000 yeah fantastic uh was 10,080
fantastic to find these
two yeah they did it ad's quietly
impressed me this week but if he really
wants to make it as a chef he's got to
decide where his L is lie no I do I do
enjoy it but I don't think I don't like
the hours I don't want to be working
those sort of hours when I'm 30 unless
I'm as rich as you and then I won't mind
you [__] can I just say when I was
your age the age of 20 there wasn't
enough hours in the [__] day for me
to work so um yeah I'd be very happy to
become successful but you got to work
for it big boy doesn't just come on a
plate where you got to read the
following it'll happen and Brian well
the success of Mama sheres depends on
his strength and his commitment more
than anybody's you've really pissed me
off this week you know that yes I felt
really bad after especially yesterday
when I realized that I haven't been
really sort of it's like I didn't care
almost I just thought when I first saw
you in the kitchen you treating it like
a job no passion but last night it came
back and I could feel it you are the
head chef yes so like the head chef yes
take responsibilities of the head chef
get a grip wake up and [__] stop
dreaming and I think Sharita knows what
she must do you are the most markable
asset
mhm of this restaurant well I'm going be
selling myself now I'm out that kitchen
understand kitchen morning a.m. hosting
the room and being present in the
evening you have got to continue that I
will do then I've got to take some
control back set a [__] example do
not be scared to get rid of
[Music]
baggage back in December I spent a week
at Mama sher's failing Soul Food shack
and I've never spent a week quite like
it I fed G
Ramsey and he cleaned his place no
discipline if you turn up for work half
an hour late in my kitchen you'd be home
for the day looking for a new [__]
job and £65,000 in debt every minute
you're in here we're losing
money [__]
hell I whipped the head chef into shape
I said no smiling no laughing serious
okay yeah you need young man [__]
rocket of your ass and the mama found
her true calling if you don't break away
from the stove mhm I swear to God the
business is going to close what's it
called just call me Mama than mama you
got it together by the end of the week
we have the shack firmly back on track
you see that empty
bowls it's a Wednesday night and I'm
just hoping the mama will be glad to
have me
back God hello oh my
God my
cousin you in the dining room of course
where else would I be I'm out of the
kitchen and so in the bowl
still going going well I mean I wish you
could have been here last night we were
absolutely full UPS on a Tuesday
upstairs and downstairs amazing stuff
wise how they going with stuff a lot
better you see Lauren's actually in a
uniform hi Lauren were you late today no
no no I came in early today actually
early early oh yes I know my moon walker
where is he oh he's upstairs he's up oh
yeah he's where he's supposed to be yeah
can I see yeah yeah go little surprise
it's great to hear that Brian sorted out
his babysitting
problems Sharita has been able to take
him on full time as Mama Cherry's head
chef and he's a changed man how you
doing big boy you well I'm fine thank
you good to see you it's nice to see you
again on weekdays he's running the
kitchen single-handed and he seems to be
thriving on the
responsibility that looks fantastic
you're not throwing things in there
anymore now you plac them in there
nicely they actually look smart better
it looks better huh it does yes what's
happened to you over the last two months
I've I've been I went through a
pH like I mean the state You Found Me In
when when you came it was of the Lords
come down and touched you i' given up
all credits to Brian he's taking soul in
a bowl and run with it it's looking
really fresh now you also get you get
starters and you get a choice of nachos
or
soup nachos nachos nachos nachos
nachos five nachos how long's it taking
now for the food to come out uh on the
tray on the tray it's taking about at
least I'd say about six seven minutes it
should be 5 minutes so quick quick as
possible as I can be yeah so you haven't
lost your touch then n no not really
it's coming back slowly you know when
you lose a bit of confidence it's kind
of difficult to sort of try and find
yourself back again you know but at the
moment I'm so into it and I'm going to
get it done whatever
happens y here we go the team has been
stripped down and the customers seem to
love their new improved food it's all
good for business smells good got some
jerk chicken your meat jumala hot wings
barbecue R January's takings are up a
staggering 60% on last year despite now
being closed on a Monday and last
Saturday sh filled the restaurant three
times over with Brian and AD cooking for
a massive 105 customers I'd love to see
you spinning around doing 105 covers you
know that yeah I bet you were Moon
walking all over the [__] shop I
didn't see the moon for a second
there okay here we go
so in the
bowl go let's see what we got here for
you tonight looks well is exactly what I
wanted him to get some confidence and
he's got that selfconfidence and walking
in and seen what you've done to the
menus can you see what I've done to the
they look fantastic you see what I've
done to the menus and I've also created
my own soul and explaining it out to
easy format no intimidation yeah and you
know when I think back to that folder
and go through those pages and all that
crap on
that a book but I think it was it was
too much taking too much that's SM
what's happening now is I've got people
coming on the weekdays ordering the s in
the bowl and then they say to me I can't
wait to book a weekend because I know
now I'm having those ribs they weren't
enough so how word you were what wasn't
happening in the business actually but
that stress was gone that the stress is
gone because now I feel that there is a
future before I didn't think there was a
future I've got that fire back inside of
me yeah and you know where the business
is going yeah and I know where where
it's going and where it can go so are
you making the perfect [__] sponge
cake um you remember that one yes I you
do I will never forget that one so if
you had to put it together now why would
it come out your cake my cake will come
out better than your
cake that means you're cooking the
books Long Live Mama cherry and her
finger licking food I'll definitely be
back for
more great great
great bet you you can't make it past 20
M 20 M you're full of [__] you know
that okay go for
it tired no not yet no not yet you look
tired you [__] whimp still going I
know give us a spin give us a spin spin
spin
spin [__]
off what's the best recipe for a
successful restaurant hurry up now it's
going to be cold top friend chefs it
looks [__] brilliant oh [__]
[__] the finest ingredients that is
incredible food Fit For A King is that
all for me larier in in vaness seems to
have it all yeah all done there's just
one thing
missing
customers without them you don't stand a
chance and I should know 2 years ago I
had to close my own restaurant and
Scotland I'm just worried that you don't
fall into the same [__] trap that I
did and I lost a lot of money this week
Kitchen Nightmares gets personal it's
been the biggest wakeup call in my
entire
life Scotland home of the brave home to
of Haggis nees and tatis and the Deep
fied marsbar
but in in vaness there's a restaurant on
a mission to bring sophisticated French
cooking to my fellow countrymen okay you
send me two PR right now please it's the
vision of French head chef Lu lefer
who's trained in some of the best
kitchens in
France I went to work for the president
in France Mr Shak when we had like Mr
Bush is coming or Japanese president is
coming used to do like big function
service one c one bra table 14 go then I
moved to work with a brother in m and
they have three Miss
star please I can't wait to meet a young
chef with such an impressive
pedigree
hello and this is the team yeah to help
realize his dream luix handpicked an
impeccably trained
Brigade suf Jeffrey has worked in
resturants with both one and two
Michigan stars did you work with L in
France no no I I came basically here uh
because it's a very good opportunity to
work with somebody three Mich staff
reges also has a Michin star studied
background how long have you been
cooking uh 8 years in France uhhuh and
uh in different country you
know and so does the junior of the team
Nicola and Nicola where about in France
are you from Britany Britany not got a
good football team there but now you
support Celtic or Rangers FC not
that's hey you're in you're an in vaness
for God's sake you got to support a
proper team and Jer is not letting the
side down either his previous jobs were
at Michin Star level as well J do you
have a Scottish girlfriend uh yes I FR
accent it's a good
point, 1400 miles from the French
Riviera luck has created a mini French
stronghold in in vaness and no one
Scottish in the kitchen no no Scottish
no Scottish there was some but not
anymore did you sack them no no no no
the first time when I came in the
kitchen I switch off the microwave put
it in a car park and 3 days after I was
by myself they got a message yeah
because they were using microwave all
the time uh powder for stock uh deep
frying everything even fond on potatoes
so I had to build a new team which is
good Lu's determined that his dream team
is going to get him his very young
Michin star bit like Roman Abramovic
when he wanted to get the Premiership
title he went around and got the best
manager the best football players and
then brought them all over to Chelsea
yeah fantastic pop that's good yeah all
done I think if you can get a Michin
star that should be great for us we are
looking to achieve like one Michin star
to to start with why not too and you
know this is new even the fridge is top
of the league it's big walking fridge
[__] H look at the size of it it's
like a one bedom flat and the produce is
the very
best flying vegetables in from France is
over the top even for me but the local
shellfish is really topnotch they are
amazing fish on SK when they come down
to London they're definitely not that
fresh I'm can to show you that is
incredible [__] me they've got the best
of everything here I mean really the
best of everything someone must be
paying a small [__] fortune to run
this place and that someone is
multi-millionaire Barry Larson hot from
his 600 acre private shooting estate he
made his fortune from the caging
business but it wasn't exactly fine
dining morning Julie how are you this is
the man who brought Kentucky Fried
Chicken wimy and Harry Ramson to
Scotland we'll see them and now he's
invested nearly 2 million trying to
prove he can make fine dining Finger
Licking Good it sounds amazing the sort
of dream team that you've put together
yeah slightly concerned about about the
expense involved in that because stream
teams don't come cheap you haven't got
any gray hair so I've got some yeah you
hiding it very well unless you die the
[__] thing no no I don't die not
yet um but no it's expensive you want
the schools Big Time have you owned
hotels no I hav't no no I haven't owned
uh hotels before we've had various
restaurants fast food chains that we've
built up sold out um family restaurants
that we we still run but obviously at a
different completely different level I
mean fast food restaurants miles away
from anything to do with fine dining
yeah but you know you still want to
produce quality for the for the for the
spend sounds fantastic but this place is
costing Barry over £8,000 a week on food
and staff costs
alone and they seem to have forgotten
the three most important things in the
restaurant
[Music]
business customers customers
customers 4 days a week the restaurant's
Dead Two soup one
and one two sandwich and every night
it's empty it's another big dent in
Barry's investment and Lu's ego
sometimes you get zero really uh yeah
must be hard that when it's zero no yeah
especially all this team here it's a
nightmare for us does it hurt yeah a bit
Yeah you got the team but you want to
play you you ready to go but oh yeah
that's difficult we like we are like
dogs you know uh when they go shooting
yeah we are ready l hungry for success
but the locals aren't biting you do me a
favor can you um read that out for me oh
gosh I can't say that b of Jerusalem
Arie choke you know what that is one
glance at his menu and I think I've
spotted the problem before I even tasted
the food not sure
deiz salmon
barlies that sounds
good how's your goues barlies that
doesn't sound re appetizer i' probably
order that
one what do you think that means this
food May appeal to the connoisseurs in
the south of France haven't got the for
but this is Scotland's smallest
city yeah would you eat that would I eat
it you can't read it you don't know what
it
isce to meet you Barry and luck want
Michelin level success but I'm afraid
they've lost sight of the basics you are
an impatient bastard yeah you want you
you you you you you want you want it and
you want to get your shopping trol go
along and get that and get that and and
you I can see it in your eyes you've had
a lot of success beforehand bringing all
these things in together it's not the
perfect recipe for an instant hit right
I'm just worried that you don't fall
into the same [__] trap that I did
and I lost a lot of money
right it was a proud day for me when I
opened amarillis in my hometown
glasa we got off to a great start and
within our first year we'd won a
Michelin star but as a menu became more
elaborate the diners started to window
right the food was so fancy it put off
the
locals they stopped coming and I was
forced to close amist
down it's a bit of a de view for me and
I'm concerned that you may be running
what too quickly too soon you know
you're in danger [__] going too
far that happened to me after 12 years
at the
top there's no doubt in L's Talent it's
his lack of experience that worries me
one SC
it's his first ever head Chef's job
there's always a big big trap they fall
in are we where they try to do too much
too soon and almost try to be sort of
competitive and thinking that what they
saw in their previous kitchen which was
in a three Mission star I've got to be
better than that and that's where a lot
of young chefs
fail could you check dou 10 for me
please you put the name and everything
huh it's my second day at L Riviera a
top restaurant with no
customers so if the locals AR aren't
eating here where are they eating busy
for
lunch [__] me 595 for two courses
starter and Main in vaness is a fast
growing city and the restaurant Market
is clearly thriving 795 is [__] cheap
isn't it now look early Sub menu two
courses
9.95 I've asked luck to serve me dinner
from his alicart menu which cost £34 for
two courses with that team in there and
the produce in the fridge is to die for
um so should be a great dinner I'm
looking forward to this one one scallop
to follow one duck the the breast pink
yes yes let's go this is your canes you
have a olive medon and a cheese be
canipes and a pre-starter this is
ambitious food for London let alone in
vanesse potato
soup with um
Wasabi very
creamy very very rich I I'm excited
about the food but I don't feel
comfortable saying
here you like a painter you need you
need you need a good eye you know like
the pain will put something like black
here and not here because for him
doesn't look right okay okay let's go
one SCS t n very complicated a lot of a
lot of um combinations of flavors going
on for me the golden rule is always keep
it simple you're tasting a broad Bean
white asparagus and citrus vinegarette
coffee tomato fennel seeds fennel
flowers shovel salad parmesan there must
be 20 things going on this plate and
then you know that looks fantastic
but doesn't do anything with him next up
duck on dur service this is a duck leg
decided to make it a ravioli on du for
the n a good um 10 to 12 flavors on the
plate again it's just confused
and your mind is sort of working over
time to try and understand what's
happening okay service please a main
course served in two parts that's just
pretentious almost like someone
um is uncontrollable and almost like a
little bit carried away and um over
excited and nothing saying just stop
come back H la la is that all for me yes
is Al Lu seems desperate to impress next
he'll be telling me how to eat it if I
to recommend you the order you've got
the tiu first please then the floating
island then you'll have the sule mhm
then the so mhm finally the carnito with
mam what L of Ballance next I'm be told
which direction to pee in because of the
[__] salmon in the
river technically flavors were amazing
the scallops were delicious mhm the um
light vinegarette yeah and did it need
the parmesan did it need the flowers and
do you need that many flavors to make it
work I won't change anything on the
flavor I think the way we work the
product um bring to the guest the flavor
that I want your
personality has to be comfortable on the
plate and I see a lot of uneasiness on
the plate I don't know if you're
confident enough in what you're doing
and I've got to be very honest because
this is very crucial but this this this
this has to
work Barry what do you think when you
think about it it's probably right that
he has
to just find his own style Barry's
acting more like a boted sugar daddy
than Luck's boss you take on somebody
like that and you're taking them on
because of their capabilities and their
ambition and you know the last thing I
want to try and do is restrain that
ambition and and what he's doing I'm not
you know I'm not a chef and I couldn't
do what he does I'm not really in a
position to criticize one one but I am
am this place isn't even breaking even
and yet Barry's forking out 4 and a half
Grand a week just on
staff it's no way to run a successful
business Barry's in love with you uh no
you're no no but no he's in love with
your food um yeah I think he like it
yeah he's never going to be your critic
and what I've got to understand is where
is your critic coming from who's telling
you to stop that's it send it when I
think it's all right don't touch it
anymore go go no wonder his food's over
the
top now I want to see how he runs his
kitchen
SC sh
freezes as every plate Journeys around
the kitchen each of his seven chefs adds
another
flourish and all this unnecessary
fussing is wasting time and money hurry
up now
yeah all
done there's so many hands that going on
around the kitchen the plate is that
normal for to go around can they not
finish anything they need my sauce the
same for the lobster I need my sauce
okay you put the plate under the grill
and I sauce
okay service please service oh one is
missing no no no it's okay it's okay
sorry [__] H it feels like we've done
and we've cooked in the last um 2 and 1
half hours is um 10 please I felt that I
wanted to just say stop what you've got
at the beginning was just enough for me
you prefer something more simpler simple
because the ingredients you've got are
phenomenal he needs to let his food
speak for itself his approach feels
outdated and pretentious is it easier if
we maybe cook a dish and like cook the
sculps and look at the difference and
and and go through it together that
way right now what should we
do
sculls um now now
whatever um I've got two things to do
okay for a guest tonight and I'll be
with
you okay if the resturant was full I
could understand his arrogance but it's
hemorrhaging cash and no one seems to
care it's almost like um the barricades
up and you know nothing's going to get
through because what I want to do is do
the dish together and look at the
different stages we're taking out to
make it more appealing but it doesn't
seem to sort of sink in I only want to
be part of the team just let me
in being hard ass is you know nice but
when you're in this situation with over
complex food and no Direction I'd
[__] grab that kind of insight if I
was in his shoes you know trust me
completely I can do what I want whatever
I want so it was the deal between us C
blanch on whatever I
do Lu's behaving like a spoiled brat so
as a last resort I'll try his Brigade is
there something you can you know work
closely with yeah cannot make it f too
complex you can help us as well I'm sure
I want to help definitely let me [__]
in yes first I'm going to tackle the
language barrier I'm going to have to
get you speaking fluent Scottish du we
Basta D we Basta no [__] D we Bast
it's getting there D we bastard sorry
it's fluent in Scottish now all right so
when someone upsets him in the High
Street D oh peace off oh peace off no
piss off piss off out of my way oh
[__]
[__] [__] hell
yeah I'm making Headway with the team
and perhaps I can get through to luck if
we're on neutral ground are you familiar
with any of the songs do you know what
they sing
here I wouldn't shout that here if
[Music]
I I'm not sure the locals will
appreciate French football songs any
more than they'll appreciate Lu's
food I look at your situation and I
can't stop comparing it to my situation
when I opened up in my hometown in
Glasgow it got too serious and then
everybody was scared to come
and then we lost a lot of money and you
know what's the point in keeping a rest
open if you're losing money and it it
broke my heart and that was my hometown
I was born there and that's what you
know I don't want to see happen with you
you're running Le Riviera um like a
three Mission star establishment you
started at such a high level I don't
know if if it such a high level I mean
um when you practice with I mean like
your chefs when they practice with you
one day they they will go by their own
what what do you think they're going to
do yeah it's a good question and chips
and fish I know but you've got to start
with the locals it's not going to
survive unless that restaurant's
[Applause]
full so what do the locals want some uh
mustard or ketchup uh mustard please
thank you have to help yourself you lazy
bastard thank you can't beat him but
anger steak sandwich
M that's not bad though that's is good
and when you've got such good local
produce you don't need to mess with it
he didn't give me my change back did he
no see he's really
Scottish it's already my third day but
nothing's sinking in surely Lou can't
ignore the evidence if it's staring him
in the
face this isn't a meal for six all this
is dinner for one at La Riviera looks
like a [__] Feast for a King Henry VI
e it's quite interesting when you um
start from one end and go the way right
to the very end it helps you to identify
where you can just draw back a little
bit and look at the whole balance of
exactly what you're doing and people
have to understand that they are here to
enjoy it so they have to spend a bit
more of time on the table like just say
okay we've got 2 hour and a half to
enjoy I couldn't eat all that
mhm I I I I'd have to stop halfway I
think I'd stop halfway yes I don't know
um if I was not able to to eat all this
I wouldn't do
it what L can't get into his stubborn
French brain is that refusing to trust
his ingredients isn't just putting off
his customers it's also a turnoff for
Michelin
inspectors maybe I can convince Barry it
is his money after after all recommend
me a whiskey I'll try to explain in
terms that any hot blooded Scotsman will
understand and one for Barry please cuz
obviously Barry's paying so can I just
have a touch of ice in there please sh
thank you do I have a touch of soda in
there please no because you're going to
spoil the completely the the the drinks
are you suggesting or telling me I'm
doing both no way soda on on a mores
there's no way no let me just say
something that you're absolutely right
you don't [__] with things that are good
and the first thing I said to livik
about the food when you've got quality
ingredients let them speak for
themselves and when you've got something
as good as that speaks volumes doesn't
need anything else no [__] Pary no
shovel no Bay no [__] fruit Garden
nothing just bang get it out do you
understand yeah I do Barry seems to be
getting it and I've got an idea that
just just might convince his Chef the
sanjac dish I want you to cook that I'm
going to cook a sanjac dish alongside
you there's a lot of way to do with him
in like yeah no no no that's what of
course it's just I'm 38 I'm 10 years
older than you yeah and so it's not
because I'm [__] 10 times better than
you I just want to make you understand
how I think yeah okay okay on what Lu
doesn't know is that I've invited xaa
inspector David Young to judge the
dishes for himself and what he won't
know is who's his
very well thank you mice and Jack dish
has just four simple ingredients as well
as the scallops it has a cauliflower
puree and a caper and raisin
[Music]
dressing long for you 30s L's dish has
at least 14 different flavors so you've
got the new season asparagus white
asparagus with a rasty scallops uh
you've got a funel arti choke and Anice
Jew and I mix it with the Fel milk okay
you've got the Parmesan crisps and
you've got the
broom thank you guys it's time to let
lck Into My Little Secret um I've
arranged for the inspector mhm the AA
guide mhm to come and taste our food
thank you go daring please so they going
to make like a
competition food inspectors are feared
and revered by chefs all over the
country
if they judge your food worthy of
missionary stars or AA rosettes the
reward is a place on the Gonic map much
thank thanks and ideally customers
beating a path to your
door willly prefer L's elaborate playful
or my simpler rendition this particular
one has much more visual impact I get
the feeling that the dish is going to
taste of exactly what was described to
me whereas this one looks a little bit
over garnished uh there's a bit of a
muddle of different types of flavors
inspectors like David can make or break
a restaurant's
reputation
Lu if Lu is going to gain a coveted
Michelin star his food really needs to
be worthy of four
rosettes how difficult David is it to
get four aoet well it's very difficult
because to put it into context as at
this moment there are only two AA
forette restaurants in Scotland in the
Hall of Scotland in the Hall of Scot SC
is it a fourstar dish what you've eaten
this one Garden yeah no no this
particular dish would be uh somewhere
between two and three rosettes mhm
whereas this dish would be probably four
rosettes mhm the combination of the
cauliflower and Caper puree just
absolutely lifted the dish into a
different dimension mhmh whereas this
one some of the flavors were over
complicated to to be frank about it and
it maybe just a case of um sometimes um
less is actually
more Lu has taken the news
badly he thinks I've stitched him
up Anglo French relations have hit an
all-time
low but time is running out at La
Riviera it's got to work hasn't it it's
your first HED job you can't afford to
[__] that will I ever make princes out
of this colony of frogs smile [__]
hell it doesn't cost anything in
Scotland I'm getting towards the end of
my week at L Riviera and I don't know if
luck is still speaking to
me last night he reacted badly when an
AA inspector confirmed that his food was
over fussy what was the first thing you
thought about this morning after um
yesterday with inspector mhm mhm what
was the was was one message you you you
learned from it um now I had your advice
I
had is his advice as well
so one you can say maybe he wrong two uh
just start to take care of him and maybe
I am
wrong um so it's a difficult thing to
accept the French Frank has finally
dropped
it's been hard for Lou but he's already
changing his game plan he's come up with
a new much simpler idea of the scop dish
it looks [__] brilliant uhhuh and
what I can identify now I know there's
Apple cuz you kept the green on there I
know there's rocket I know there's
pumpkin seed and it it makes me feel
comfortable because I know what I'm
about to eat yeah I can identify what
you're
doing that that's delicious and
everything that goes on the plate has to
have a reason not for this but for here
for the pet yeah for the pallet and what
you've just done there L you've given
your food clear Insight okay I
understand it's not three four five is
that for me I'd be happy eating that
anywhere you know that where's that
[__]
inspector [__] now halleluia I've
just taken [__] France now luck has
finally swallowed his pride we can be to
move
forward with his team behind him maybe
he has a chance of achieving his
ultimate goal um you told me that you
wanted a michion star and at first I
didn't think that was possible you know
that because of how things got so
complicated but with this here there's
no two ways about it it's definitely
worth the
star I respect Lu for taking it on board
because it's [__] hard lesson very
hard lesson but you know it's got to
work hasn't it it's your first head job
you can't afford to [__] that crucial
you've got the right training now you've
got the perfect position to do
it but winning over the kitchen is only
half the
battle Carolyn is the Mater D and she's
also L's
girlfriend she's responsible for writing
the elaborate menus and have already
discovered that the locals haven't got a
clue what they mean it's time to turn
the tables read that for
me good crunching peppered with massed
tatis
nice D we
busted to prove a point I've given them
a menu of classic Scottish dishes what
do you think it is something sexy uh
something um spicy ttis
tties L what do you think that one is
there this one here BR is for far and
winter in salad of
grills no idea at all what is Queen Mar
Mar and we the crumble crunch do you
have any idea what I'm trying to say
it's impossible to choose anything you
don't understand exactly it's exactly
it's difficult for make a choice when
you have this one because yes it's
difficult for [__] Scotland to
understand you guys that's what I'm
trying to say yeah he same so it's less
intimidating if you have an assortment
of salmon um you know a selection of
you're in you understand what I'm trying
to say at last I'm getting somewhere
just look at what you're taking to the
table and [__] hell you know it's
like you're a
librarian you should see what it's like
when the table are sat and six of them
are looking in here you've lost
everybody yeah yeah there's no dinner
anymore because everyone's behind a
brick wall you can simplify the whole
thing just one beautiful open card Stars
man
so everything going down there has
simplified it and it's not just the
menus that need lighting up smile mon
smile he's far better looking when he's
smiling smile [__] hell it doesn't
cost anything in
Scotland tried it well tried yeah oh
[__] hell throw him in the river
we're supposed to be in a
restaurant not a Sunday School Church
service where's my Bible
Barry's grasp the nettle and has radical
plans to transform the dining room going
to take this column away yep going to
take the raised area away at the back on
that side so we've got at a cost of
£35,000 the arches over the doors we're
going to square off yeah and then it's
all panel mhm all the way around some
nice artwork it doesn't look that bad
does it and it it does look I don't
think it looks particularly it's not
glamorous but it's not glamorous it's
not shitty no but it's just not I just
think it's doesn't look right but I've
got a lowc cost idea which I think will
give larier a unique selling
point I said
salad I'd like you to start thinking
about having a table in the kitchen
where you have local to come and sit and
eat it starts to break up the sort of
wall that you know some times you have
when you come to a strange new country
as I've discovered having a chef's table
in the kitchen is a great way to bring
customers into your world and keeping
the chefs on their
toes and this would be the first
restaurant in Scotland to have one I
think this this will be the best place
is definitely yeah just in a corner and
they will see everything everything and
it can help create something exciting in
vaness can you imagine the buzz going
around town the chef table could be a
way of showing off and establishing your
reputation here and be be be first think
it's exciting idea yeah it
is I mean for once we going to see how
do the people react if it's no good I
mean like just to throw it to take care
about this hopefully they won't do that
super but it all costs money and
although the chef table is a great
investment until they've got customers
coming in they need to make economies
elsewhere crab F and hand dive scallops
which are King scallops so I mean the
rolls Roy of ingredients I mean
everything's here [__]
hell luck needs to do what I did when I
started out learn to use good cheap cuts
to put together an inspiring menu you
ever use a shin
lug no Ox making something Exquisite
from a shin of beef or an ox Tong takes
a lot of skill the size of
my thank you I love it and it's a great
way to identify Talent right
um oxil You you and you reggies a little
competition want you to cook a dish come
up with something really exciting and
then L and myself will look at it and
the most tastiest delicious dish will
put on the lunch menu and for me the
most important thing about this is
always a sign of a very very good cook
to turn something something very very
cheap into something quite special so R
just take it to bed and think about it
okay next morning I'm pleased to see the
young chefs have taken their oxtail
challenge seriously pasta yes and uh
it's very you know y nice and long very
wrong yep roll it put it back into St
shape from the beginning that's a good
idea yeah
juice reduction reduction uh glass like
a yeah um the oxel dises for the lunch
menu are almost ready and they've each
cost about a quid to put together so
this is bra do St with uh winter
V dishes like these are not only highly
profitable but bringing together great
Scottish produce with French flare is a
winning for me I like the Jew and just a
bit of Australia yes tastes delicious
with a white root vegetables it made it
feel earthy and and and together yeah
who's next and despite what L thinks
simplifying his dishes will actually
make them more likely to win
Awards I've never had oel and sesame SE
together before michion inspectors never
reveal their criteria but I know from
experience that beautifully cooked food
is not enough next inspectors look for
good quality ingredients ideally
Regional and definitely in season and I
put carrots mhm celer this idea is great
and the balance of flavors is crucial
very rich it needs a salad yeah it's
quite rich and what I like is you put
the salad just next to and not on a
plate like this you can choose but first
and foremost don't confuse the mission
inspector's pallette by putting too many
ingredients on the plate never expected
anyone fren to come up with a Jack and
potato stuffed thank you the simpler the
better um what do you
think re mhm flavors are very good what
you managed to do is to bring out the
true flavor of lox tail bu thank you
okay Mel Gibson any one of these dishes
would be worthy of a place on the lunch
menu but we're choosing just one I want
to see if luck and I will agree on the
winner I'm going to touch my plate which
I'd like on the lunch menu and you touch
the plate after 3 yeah okay 1 2 3
you well
done well done let's go was real and
authentic Scottish food yep that's I
think he understood really understood
where we want to go with luck leading
the way we're ready to relaunch the
restaurant for me it's a critical stage
for any restaurant is to get a lunch
full and if our customers have an
enjoyable lunch chances are that we back
for a more expensive alart dinner and
when they leave with a bloody good lunch
good prices I can guarantee by the time
5:00 in the afternoon hits you know
they've told 100 people go there for
dinner because I had a fantastic lunch I
want to see if we can push this starter
M and dessert 1 hour
[Music]
yeah as well as the new oxtail dish the
menu will include mackerel pheasant and
goat cheese ravioli venison from Barry's
estate tuna and the cheapest cut of pork
customers sometimes are scared about
belly of Paul thinking fat greasy we've
taken the pat off rolled it um spiced on
a bed of spinach um it's a caramelized
onion puree have a taste if you
[Music]
wish and I've got some other ideas to
give Scottish traditional dishes a
modern twist this is a soup that doesn't
look pretty uhh but tastes amazing they
wouldn't expect the Frenchman to make a
cck soup which is a really nice way of
um you know putting your identification
on
it uh L just an idea for the rice
pudding yeah we grew up with this kind
of food so we can go a little bit
further caramelized pineapple mango or
even marinade the prunes in a nice malt
whiskey y
[Music]
y the kitchen's finally turning out the
kind of food that I know will definitely
appeal to the
locals and even the waiters have
promised to try and
smile but there's one more thing to
complete the transformation you got to
come with me now because we're going to
become even more
[Applause]
[Music]
Scottish any ideas yet briges have you
ever taken your knickers off before no
no chance to show a us your Scotch eggs
okay it's time for luck and his small
colony of French comrades to surrender
themselves to the
[Music]
Scots [__] hell the things I'll do to
get the Arrogant French to become a
little more Scottish is amazing you know
that it's
cold how do you put it on we don't wear
punch
underneath it's wonderful very hot and
very
sexy hey there's 25 very important
guests coming for lunch yes but some
really good news uhhuh they're all
women very powerful women
super if they can impress 25 influential
local business women they'll be the Talk
of the
Town two for guest one potato soup
vegetarian three o
one one
[Music]
tuna
okay I want two M two one o okay watch
your legs watch your's
legs at last Lu's team are beginning to
dance to a different
[Music]
tune the food looks really good clear
and
simple everyone's cing ready well was
the first time I've actually seen a real
taste of Scotland in this kitchen it's
about [__] time just have to L's on
his way to the top of the Premier
League wonderfully presented it's
gorgeous and judging by the reaction of
his fans he's definitely scored
absolutely Divine just perfect
absolutely perfect beautiful you
couldn't Vault anything really I I would
imagine normally this sort of food you'd
be talking at least a couple of hours
for lunch but to get something like this
in that time skill brilliant it's
beautiful have you
this and okay it's for you a present
thank
you excuse me what the [__] is that who
is
that I think it's a big chef and what is
that
there BS BS yeah trust me I have a big
pair of pols Al blue yeah thank you yeah
Chin Chin
Chin luck and his team have come a long
way this week and if he sticks to my
keepit simple Mantra I think larra
Vieira might be on the right track for a
Michelin
star
[Applause]
outside just for the ladies Regis to
understand that you really are part of
Scotland now we're all going to turn
around turn around turn around turn
around ready 1 2 3
go right Lu it's been two months since
oat La
Riviera have you missed me a little bit
yeah so what's changed okay you take one
for one rable for the menu looks lovely
and you've got um cheaper ingredients on
Ox cheek for the lunch menu yeah uh-huh
I'm dying to taste the pork cheese can
you cook me one please yeah of course
yeah with the uh risotto it looks lovely
oh yeah it's very
nice that looks interesting is that the
chef's table yes I'm finishing the chef
table very impressed with that that
looks great yeah it's good to see he's
actually done my
advice but the proof of the pudding is
in the eating here we are M thank you
L um the PO chick is
Oto and chant a dish with just four
ingredients absolutely delicious that
for me so far is one of the most
tastiest dishes I've ever eaten here
uhhuh really really delicious if you
continue like this this place is only
going to just get busier and busier and
busier that's what we want that's a
great dish to be proud of thank you
how's the refer been going on in the
dining room dining room is finished for
one week
now wow [__] me what a difference not H
it looks like L more um slick smart
Barry must have spent a fortune on it
beautiful uh dark pan W um a completely
different dying room it is it is another
rest it feels more relaxed but is it
money well spent has anything improved
since the last time I was here yeah the
restaurant's bookings have improved
uhhuh we just you know look to what you
told us mhm on simplifying the menu
writing the menu Mission St I would I'd
love to get one but what's more
important for me at the moment is that
we build the customers it's certainly
come a long way from the resturant I
found two months ago yeah I'm done his
food was so elaborate go there must be
20 things going on this plant it had
frightened off the
customers hurry up now he was desperate
for a Michin St but reluctant to let me
help but by the end of the week R just
take it to bed and think about it the
message message had sunk in Hallelujah
I've just taken [__] France and we
were able to fill the stuffy restaurant
with happy
diners his dream was to win Awards and
with his newly simplified food I thought
luck was finally producing dishes worthy
of a missioning
star it looks [__] brilliant where's
that [__]
inspector this time round I raised the
bar even higher with another surprised
visitor for luck last time I saw this
man he actually gave me three Mission
Stars so um perhaps the most revered and
feared critic in the
world Derek Brown is the grand fromage
of restaurant inspectors hi Derek he's
the ex president of the missioning guide
and he's agreed to do me a favor I'm not
going to say too much about this
particular um Resturant but um he's a
very intriguing talented individual and
just would love to see what you think
what he's a capable of doing now
remember you don't know me don't know
your at top secret sure
headchef luck has no idea he has such an
influential critic in his restaurant
won't ask if youve been through for his
sake I hope Derek goes for the simple
pork cheek I had the lamb please the
lamb damn how would you like it cooked
so um Pink Please
pink to me the Scottish Lamb with
stuffed baby Arch chokes looks just as
elaborate as it did two months ago I see
you got your herb guard in back I'm from
the south of France so her is very
important for me I hope to God I'm wrong
you can't eat
it I can't wait to see L's face when he
realizes that the food he's sending out
now is for the ex president of michelan
he's going to [__] his French
knickers time for the Moment of Truth L
do seconds play L do you know this S
one no sorry Mr Derek Brown L I think
I've seen you yeah already yes maybe in
France somewhere I'm dying to find out
I'm sure luk as well how was lunch well
it was very interesting your Technique I
mean you've been very careful about the
whole preparation of each of your dishes
but you know it was too complicated
there were 10 different flavors on the
plate mhm there was garlic and herbs in
the Artio which is itself a delicate
thing little bit overpowering I thought
the shoulder which You' done a comy of
that was the tastiest part of the dish
the million dollar question was lunch
worthy of a Missy star I would I would
say that you you have not got very far
to go I never gave advice in my working
life before but if you want me to give
you some advice I would simplify what
you're doing mhm make sure that the
customers are going to be happy with
every dish that you ever make them and
things like stars from The Michelin
guide will follow the old boys have got
to be replaced so it's up to you and and
you've got the talent just just use it
and refine
it but has the message really sunk in or
is he still intent on forcing over
elaborate French food on the local
this is our challenge this is not to
bring people like you do in London the
challenge is to teach them and to bring
them in that's why you have to make
something really special [__] me my my
my frustrating thing is that You' really
got to understand the message because
you know I [__] said this from day
one and I'm not an inspector I'm a chef
and I say it from your
level will he ever understand that
simple can also be special one summon
one venm so are you feeling a little
nervous about the chef table in the
kitchen tonight for the first time if
they see a
nightmare they're going to say look this
[__] French is [__] crazy no I
think they'll be very happy with the
[__] nightmare with a fully booked
Russian
tonight and his first diners in the
kitchen Lu should be a very happy man
okay uh
mon good evening good evening I hope
you're glad to be the first in my
kitchen table um I will make a bit of
music for you if you want I can I can
manage this we never be the best of mes
but we do have one thing in
common ambition remember what he said
that thing about 12 or 15 things on one
plate so next time you put a dish
together and you've gone past 8 nine 10
things on the plate give me a [__]
call cuz I'm coming back when you get to
11: okay
Al yes good luck tonight yes cuz I think
you're going to [__] need
it I sincerely hope he makes it a
success who knows maybe the Miss sty
will follow
[Music]
come